foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
to anyone
all around the world are you kidding me
the chess.com Global Championship offers
the dream of playing against the best
whoa and hey have we mentioned there's
also a million dollars at stake the
total pot is a million dollars know that
it's not a typo their prizes are
unbelievably generous we began with
thousands of players now only dozens
remain you don't just do this to chakra
in a critical game except Alexis Verona
just did gorgeous chess he makes his way
into the round of 16.
The cgc Knockout phase has arrived
there are those who played their way in
and some are here thanks to their
well-earned reputation
no matter who you are they things are
about to get very very real
Duda moves on to the round of 16 a trip
to the cgc finals and a clean shot at
the largest first place prize of the
year
my friends it's the cgc round of 32. who
will take the next step to Toronto
[Music]
welcome back to the 2022 chess.com
Global Championship I'm Grandmaster
Robert Hess alongside me as
International Master Levy Rosman Levy we
had a fun day of Chess yesterday we have
four excellent matches to start this
early Saturday yeah we do if there was
ever a reason to wake up early it was
today because we have basically 50 of
all of our mashups in The Knockout
rounds we're bringing you the entire
unit groups f and g to start and then
we're moving to some of the other groups
for the later part of the day yesterday
we saw some ups and downs we saw some
blunders we saw in a mortal game uh and
before we get into the amazing action
today we just have some Logistics to run
you through Robert uh take it away
yes sir well it is a single elimination
knockout you should all be familiar with
that so if your favorite player loses in
a Four game match if someone gets to
tune up points that means their opponent
is eliminated and if it is tied two to
two Armageddon will be the theme of the
day and Levy we haven't seen Armageddon
recently here in the round of 32 but in
the opening round it was left and right
and a lot of fun yeah it was probably
the most iconic one of round of 32 was
Sam Savion taking down mdl he also maybe
played in The Mortal game uh and then
celebrated the prime very close to the
biggest upset I think of the round of 32
you can argue surrounded but I think
obviously Savion uh mvl is up there I
think npl might have been the top five
pick maybe top six pick uh yeah the
Armageddon is a fascinating format you
bid for your time between white and
black and uh I think we have a preview
of everything we're seeing today I'm
actually in shock of how many superstars
are on this in this Robert like just it
was just it's an amazing magic but as
this event keeps going there's no
Slackers if you want to make any sort of
argument for the Dark Horse of the
tournament I mean you got to just put it
all a biograph at this point you beat
vishy I mean what's what's another world
champion right uh prediction that he'll
beat uh World rapid Champion today
you know I don't think the odds are in
his favor but he did beat Vichy that
means that he can pretty much be anybody
in this format and as we look at these
four matchups you mentioned in nishikiri
he's taking on Roundup sedwani whose age
belies his experience I mean the guy is
playing all the time title Tuesday's
bullet rapid events it doesn't matter
he's there so I think Anish will have
his hands full uh but I think we all
have to draw our attention to the bottom
right matchup between Vladimir kramnik
and nihal sarin because Levy either of
these players I don't think you'd be too
surprised if they won this whole thing
no no you wouldn't I mean of course they
they might not be as uh much of a
household name when talking about rapid
favorites like Abdul Satori right uh
Nakamura but nihal Saran can hang with
the best of the best he's one of the
young Indian players who I didn't at any
moment can play like a 2750 2800 now the
fascinating thing to me about this
matchup is that Vladimir cranbic might
be three times his age like roughly and
uh if it gets down into those nasty time
scrambles now sorry that's three
thousand that bullet and Hyper bullet
and it'll be uh it'll be quite a
nightmare we zoom out here to our uh
kind of overall bracket uh some of the
players have already moved on to a round
of 16. some of them have even moved on
to a matchup in a round of 16 so today I
believe we're closing out the rest of
them with the exception of one as we
wait for Timur jawab and Arjun Eric icy
every guy see for obvious reasons he
might just go in one tournament then
come right back here and win another one
uh let's take a look at Group G let's
take a look at how we got here uh we've
got kramnik who defeated Malcolm Young
strong player from Armenia the house
started to tell Ralph momentov you were
you commentating that thing how was that
game where he won with like three
seconds on the clock with black in
America
it was unbelievable I mean it seemed
like Ralph was gonna have a huge upset
in the opening round and nihal sarin
showed off his bullet skills his mouth
speed and I think Vladimir krumnick was
maybe the most impressive player if the
entire round of 64. he swept front
mokumian who's a very strong player he
made it look easy and on the top side of
this bracket though Levy dingley Ren he
looked a bit shaky against men we have a
lot of respect for men but dingley Ren
you you got to win that matchup uh and
sail through the next round so Andre
yesapanko maybe he feels like he's a
good shot I was gonna say that yeah we
have a lot of respect obviously for
midnight and England both but that is a
number one versus number eight matchup
that's not surprising if it ends two and
a half
I think if anybody gets Credit in that
match it's probably been late for
stepping up but at the same time yes uh
ding definitely I think could have
performed a bit better and today he's
not going to really be able to uh let it
get super close I think because I
tippenko knows what it's like to taste
Glory at the highest level you also
commentated on the game I believe that
he beat Magnus Carlson over the board
that wasn't
that was a game he was like one of the
youngest in fact I think he was the
youngest of the time to beat him in a
classical game because he the youngest
still maybe to beat him in a classical
game during his Raiders world champion
so he knows what it's like okay to go up
against the best and to beat the best
and uh I think this is one of our only
groups where it's one two three four in
the round of 32. it's a very balanced
all the favorites are moving on no
upsets thus far but today that might
change
yeah that's different from group F which
features anishkiri is the top seed we
see one three five seven so some upsets
I don't really think roundex had wanted
beating uh was much of an upset given uh
the fact that to Paul is largely retired
and doesn't play as much online but
pancrata that was the biggest upset of
the first round yeah it's gonna be very
interesting for me to see how release
handles uh another young Indian Prodigy
I mean the man has had his hands full
playing in the online tour he's played
against go cash he's played against Eric
geisey who is just a Savage he's played
against the halsar and he's played
against fragment the list goes on and on
you just keep naming players Ronald said
one of his I think right underneath that
tear but he's still an absolute Beast as
we see his rapid rating on Tesla pound
2700 he was on Team India which got
bronze and almost got a gold medal and
we have a player profile on him to show
you all
impressively one of five Junior players
from his country rated over 2600.
age 13 round Knox adwani became just the
ninth youngest Grandmaster in history
sedwani has momentum coming off a
memorable performance this summer at the
44th Olympiad in which his team of
outstanding youngsters were able to
defeat the top seeded United States and
ultimately grab the bronze medal
competing and playing number nine of the
cgc in Late July saidwani foreshadowed
his success to come in the Olympiad
notching eight of the nine available
points oh my gosh what a play from
around San Juan he's really putting on a
show right now
ironically enough to secure his spot in
the round of 64. said Juani still had to
get through another teenage Sensation
from India pranav V
unfazed saidwani sealed the deal
in the main bracket the 16 year old star
finds himself in a challenging
experienced group
in another twist sadwani's first round
opponent was the fide Champion the same
year sidwani was born what a performance
by Raonic sawani I mean he just came in
throwing Haymakers he played this game
like somebody had bet on him to win in
the third round but he was just gonna
put it away
saidwani will need to tap into more
Magic from his fruitful summer to make
travel plans to Toronto it's Apollo is
one of the best players of all time but
in today's game it's been all around it
I don't think I've ever seen people play
like that before and he might have had
the most convincing three games of the
day
and that was a great profile of raunak
Sudani who today faces a niche giri it's
the one versus the five an invited
player versus a qualified player and
Levy anishikiri has to be the favorite
at least in terms of how their ratings
stack up but Radix and wani will not go
down without a fight no absolutely not I
think in some ways that the last line
here of this preview is the important
one he got invited you got qualified one
man you know came up from nothing you
know what I'm saying he uh he had to
earn his way here he had to claw he had
to fight he had to knock down another
young Indian genius in V pronounced
three thousand rated Blitz player and
he's Geary he got a he got a black card
you know he was like he got the VIP uh
ropes uh kind of like come right in of
course he did have to win that first
round matchup on his own and he did in
fact do that but listen I feel like the
young Indian players are hungry they're
they're a different breed at at moment's
notice they can pull off a great upset
and today we have an opportunity to see
two of them take on former 2800 rated
players that's one thing that people
might not even know about a niche I
think he was 2800.2 I think in the
middle of a tournament like this is a
former 2800 classical rated player and
he is quite quite solid at rapid I think
as far as this matchup goes where it
might get tricky is in those low time
scrambles I think Anisha has very strong
preparation uh in the openings and I
think he will poke in produce at the
money but he's only got four games to do
so before Armageddon which as we know
could be a total circus
it certainly can be and we know how
strong Runner said wani is but the
community doesn't seem to be as behind
him as I would have thought because of
those who predicted this matchup and
that's not that many I guess people
thought to paulov that's a big name that
they figured he would win but only 11 of
people who predicted this matchup
thought Raonic said Ronnie would win
that is shocking to me maybe even more
shocking than Andre casapenko only
getting eight percent of the vote
yeah both of those are a bit a bit crazy
but listen we've seen crazier things I
definitely think that said one is at
least the 25 right because okay you
could say that Alicia's three to one
favorite I believe that's how odds work
if not then I'll just completely stop
talking about odds but if you have to
give me a percent chance for an age I
think maybe between 60 and 70 but it's
because he's an age right so he's going
to get the positions from the opening he
will kind of push that pace I actually
am not as familiar with romx at one he's
playing style as maybe some of the other
guys like I don't know if he's a
universal player like uh or if he
prefers to test some more tactical
positions I I don't know if there's a
world where he can take a niche out of
the territory of the comfort zone of the
opening because it really seems like a
niche against people outside of the top
five top ten the immediate top five top
10 at least in something like classical
Robert it just seems like a niche will
take around like exactly where he wants
in the opening but if he fails to do
that maybe Veronica's actually very very
good chances yeah and Veronica showed
great preparation in the Olympiad that
certainly has helped his preparation and
his confidence but Anish giri is one of
the best prepared players on the planet
has been for quite a long time so the
games are getting underway here we have
um nordybeck Abdul sitarov starting
against aval pankratov and turanik
sedwani and then he's curious they'll
start their game any moment as well but
we see in English we see early G3 and
then the thrust D5 from Pavel
yeah I was I thought this game was
actually admittedly going to start about
five minutes later I did not realize
that it was going to start right now I
felt like we hyped up uh Geary and
sadwani and then all of a sudden Mojo
crack is like yo what about me I'm World
rapid champ where's my intro bozos and
we do see him playing a pretty pretty
rare move order here I've never seen I
mean I've seen B3 but generally I
thought you would be putting out the
Deep on first uh this is a super
Universal setup right by the way there
was like a million different game lines
oh not anymore not after F5 F5 is a very
concrete move from the crowded but he
wants E4 after which white is going to
get pushed back
and you have to kind of tip your
proverbial cap to Pavel ponkarato
because he's not afraid of anybody and
people say who who is this guy you need
Vichy now he's playing the world rapid
Champion he doesn't care who he faces
he's just going for the best moves and
he had a very bad game four against
Vichy and he needs to avoid that kind of
collapse because noribbeck is not going
to let him back in the match if he is
handing out free points
whoa look at his camera by the way
what's his oh yeah I was gonna say he
has like burning rays of light coming
down uh over his head I I'm not gonna
say a little tough it's a little tough
to deal with uh noji reg once again is
in his album cover room uh although I
think is that a chessboard now behind
him on the bottom right side okay okay
we added a few things I see a table now
I don't think I don't think we saw that
last time uh Anish Geary versus Ronald
savoni has in fact started
um
so let's go let's go take a look
whoa
whoa what is this 14 moves deep more
time than he started with as Niche Curry
we'll go through it but it started as an
Italian and this position is all the
rage these days retro C3 black plays A5
just to make sure that white doesn't get
to expand on the queen side with B4 but
Levy as we've seen time and time again
in this variation with this move Bishop
B5 a white simply removes the Bishop
from the trade and takes his Knight and
C6
yeah and that's why black plays this
move Queen B8 it looks completely bogus
but it's multiple ideas here the the
main one being that the B file opens it
quite takes on C6 but also there's Queen
to A7 we saw this in the candidates we
saw dignity Run play this against Hikaru
if I'm not mistaken uh there's another
line instead of Knight bd2 early where
white can move the bishop up to G5 I
hate to pull you back from a theoretical
point we just want to show the chat like
sometimes white plays in a very
provocative way Bishop G5 and then black
has to thrust the king side pawns
forward and each year he decides I'm
really not in the mood for all this so
instead of doing that let's play this
kind of more solid approach but the way
the way it's looking on the board right
now it does resemble that candidates
game doesn't it you know you know what
I'm talking about where that Bishop on
B6 like slowly had to break out it was
that it was the the game where ding was
down an hour but then totally flipped
the script and then actually Hikaru was
the one defending for a bit so a very
very theoretical position looks like uh
ramek doesn't remember which against a
niche could be a problem
yeah and look at rounding he's got his
head on his desk he's not even looking
at the board he's desperately trying to
remember something anything that can
help him in this position because as we
look at the pawn structure white has
four pawns to three from the e to the H
file these are double pawns a rook can
come to C1 and if you don't get the move
C5 in and he plays it the bishop is
imprisoned on B6 so C5 is played and
let's see Levy how quickly Anish
responds because he might be leaving his
prep soon
yeah
um
see a trade on C5 nothing too major and
uh by the way a niche looks very young
today
he looks kind of like he's uh
trying to be the teenager in this match
but of course Anish he's been uh at the
top of the Chess World since he's a
teenager so it's a
good to see
Veronica wani he's a an approving player
in his own right and so this D4 Square
that's what I'm looking at uh if we can
trade Bishops bring a knight to D4 and
it feels like white has gained some
important space in the center
Robert do I sound better
uh you've always sounded good to me
lovey oh
thank you well I uh I've I've
reconnected here to our uh to our
commentary program uh we did see we did
see the chat mentioning uh about my
microphone I was under the impression
that everything was all good like it
always is but as it turns out when your
Windows updates overnight and then you
wake up at 5 30 a.m you sometimes don't
always check that the microphone
settings got changed that's uh
unfortunately how it works sometimes in
the digital world one day everything is
going good and the next day your
computer removes your default uh
microphone so my sincere quality chat
you can hear us better now
so here's the question did Raonic figure
out what he was supposed to do correctly
in this position because he got to a
spot I got to tell you I like anisha's
position I like the C file and I like
the fact that his Knight can go to D4
and I also like F4 F5 so I'm really high
up on this position for a niche
so am I I don't care what the eval Bar
says slightly better for white but I
think practically speaking it could be
very dangerous for black that said if
this Knight moves out the way and this
Pawn gets to C5 all of a sudden I'm
believing in Black's position so it is
one of these double-edged positions at
least in the future it'll likely get
double edged but I'm totally with you
Olivia I'm liking the layout here for
white just feels like there's some
natural moves that can be played and the
bishop on E6 not the best Bishop in the
world doesn't have anything to attack
it's really just a defensive piece
and I think for that reason that Bishop
will probably be moved at some point or
he will be okay with it being captured
if white goes Knight D4 or something but
I also yeah black is gonna play Queen B6
black is gonna play Queen before black
is gonna also play A4 A3 I like it it
it's much easier to make the moves on
Black's board and draw arrows than
actually come up with a concrete plan
and uh that's what makes this position
very easy to handle from the from the
wide standpoint yeah there's there
there's Knight D Force like what is what
is roundick's move right now maybe we
can even let him think about it let's go
check in on dingley run which just
started
let's do it dingley run he's taking on
Andre yesapenko so we're gonna bring
this board up and and we tuned in at a
good time because after a quiet little
opening here dingley red playing a lot
of these ready and English positions
here he plays E4 so he says please have
my Pawn in the center but this would be
a huge mistake everybody not all pawns
should be captured you're opening up the
e-file uh this Pawn E5 will be captured
this Knight E4 is loose so this would be
a tactical problem for black
yes it would this is such a interesting
choice from dingly Wren I mean I I
to have never seen him play an opening
like this have you
it's very weird to see this position and
both sides wish their Knight was not on
the f file so they could push the F Pawn
but when you play copycat chess and this
is what the position has been white
moves first and yesmail continues to
copy and mirror what dingley wren's
doing but at some point it has to stop
yeah it does it does because if white
delivers Checkmate black doesn't get
checkmate in response that might be a
little bit exaggerated but they're wow
this has all happened before though I
think petrogen has some games here uh
the one from the mid 20th century uh and
now yes cbab and I I've studied this
years ago and I was always laughing
about the fact that black can just
actually get away with this you know
there's like and I don't remember the
plan after B5 like I think white doesn't
always have to take but he can but this
is just hilarious I mean justifengo's
like I'm gonna copy you and dingley runs
like stop copying me you know it's like
when you when you would annoy your
friends when you were a kid uh Robert I
I don't wow there it is cbab what's
what's the move here to break the
symmetry
I guess D4 will happen and you can't
just play D5 but you say when you're
kids no people to this day when I'm
playing Blitz they will copy me and it
really pisses me off right it's so
infuriating when somebody is just
intentionally and trying to get under
your skin by playing the exact same
moves you do yeah it is it's it's it can
be very very annoying of course at this
level that's not exactly the strategy
he's not just copying him to copy him
he's copying him because it's one of the
main lines and that's that's what he's
going to do and uh if you want to punish
him you got to beat him right that's
that's the only way but uh other than
that
well it's it's uh yeah he's he he's
copying him uh literally to a t now the
reason I was just saying in case people
are confused why I've never seen this
from being the red I think he runs a D4
player not only is it D4 players D4
Mainline player plays Catalan he plays
Knight F3 Knight C3 not only have I
never seen like when's the last time
dingley run played E4 when's the last
time he played already especially in
like top levels topple level games I
don't know
yeah he started playing the English more
and more uh I don't know what changed
like what that inspiration was but you
are correct the dingler historically has
been somebody who goes uh through the
main lines he's afraid of nothing he's
afraid of nobody uh but yeah he's been
mixing it up a bit which I actually
think has been good for his chest not
that he needs any unsolicited advice
from me but I do think it has been very
good for him no it's okay I feel like it
was it was in fact solicited yes this I
guess this is becoming in English with
with the move c2c4 that's the thing
about ready English it can basically be
a ready it can be in English you play
you play Knight F3 on move one so that
your opponent cannot play E5 that's
really that's really why you do it uh
rookie one so will we see Rook E8 all
right how stubborn is Andre acipenko
going to be yours is he gonna is he
gonna do something else maybe H6
preventing Knight G5
all I know is I just got distracted
because it looks like dingley Ren is
becoming holy like you see this light
behind him no and you know the guy is
already a Shining Light of Chess I don't
think he needs it in his background and
yes a panko's like massaging his temples
like the guy seems stressed yeah he does
he does he does seem stressed and he
said don't listen I don't think he's
that stressed he's probably just
thinking all right at what point will
dingley Wren get insulted that I'm
copying him the entire game it's been 15
moves of total symmetry ding's probably
like yo what is this that's why I don't
play these stupid openings because they
get positions that look like this uh
this is very funny I love I love how
chess as an esport
I don't know if they do this in other
Esports during the commentary like in
chess it's so fun to see the players on
camera because we don't we see them in
suits we see them face to face we see
them shaking hands live over the world
we never see them like this we never see
them just what does their home setup
look like right in 2022 does it look
like they're on 2007 webcams not These
Guys these guys got the good cams got
good lighting uh
anyway uh speaking of speaking of good
camera good lighting you know old versus
new uh cram nicknam has that started
it has indeed so and this is the
position we have where double isolated
pawns which would make most people shake
their heads and cry is what krumnick has
accepted so we can go through the
opening see how we got here and speaking
of maybe a little unusual move order C4
from chrome oh yeah
and he just English is all the rage
these days
yeah wow it really is A3 here okay G3
okay but yeah I mean G3
uh the game between uh girian pankrative
was uh sorry I just I just a few some
matchups another back and pankrative was
not this line but it was wow E4
and
yeah accepting the damaged Pawn
structure but white gets the bishop pair
if I could compare the two we just
watched the position Robert that was 15
moves completely copycat symmetrical
this looks like some sort of Salvador
Dali painting you know it's like a move
ago it did with the doubled Knights and
almost the whole C file stack yeah this
is like some Modern Art you know like so
or wow Knight takes E6 but what about
the pawns I thought the whole point of
keeping the knight at the center was
that at some point you could undouble
your pawns but cramlington you don't
care he's just like
want to play Rook D1 good luck ever
getting out
and that was so surprising because black
couldn't play D6 or B6 with the tension
of the knights here so a rook D1 first
is what I was looking at but yeah he
takes on E6 and I'm just gonna trust
Vlad right yeah he's the former world
champion and Neal takes with the Rook on
E6 also a bit unexpected because the
bishop is uh stuck back here but that's
just the one we want to do continuous
development so Levy I'm starting to like
the position for black what do you make
of things
yeah me too if black successfully plays
Bishop D7 and B6 like White's pawns are
dead that's white he played C5 exactly
that's because that's one of the ways
you can get rid of your double pawns
here and now he's just deliberating
whether to play Rook a or Rook fd1 that
that million dollar question of which
Rook to move you know I kind of like
Rook a because I I have this hope that
white can play E4 F4 and then the F Rook
should stay where it is I don't know if
you agree with me or if you want to play
Rook fd1 or Rook ab1 but he just takes
on C5 but yeah Robert like what what do
you think you like my plan or you want
to play Rook fd1 and then keep the a
rook where it is
I really like your plan especially
because it's a bishop pair Advantage so
black you know sorry wants to play
Bishop B7 and maybe Knight A5 and if the
light Square bishops come off in a way
that's acceptable for black uh things
are not going to be so easy for white on
the light squares what you want to do is
take over the C4 Square so
um I like the way nehal is playing this
and chromatic has a big decision right
now does he bring one of these Rooks to
D1 and I like Rook a to D1 more for sure
and if that's the case is there going to
be a problem on the E file on this E2
Pawn like things are a bit hanging for
kramnik yeah but kramnik has made a
career winning kind of fianchetto G2
Bishop mildly imbalanced position sort
of structures like if you just look at
this position yeah I completely agree I
would much prefer to play black but if
you tell me I have to play Black against
Vladimir crab Nick I'll just leave I
won't even finish the game I'm not going
to I'm not going to it's it's just it
ain't happening right like you trust
your own instincts in most cases but in
the case of kramnik well nehal Saran
probably still continues to trust his
instincts as part of being a very
confident kind of young Rising Star but
I gotta tell you Bishop pair and
kramik's going to continue to hammer
away C4 C5 and so on I don't know if
black will find the right coordination
to actually utilize the benefit of his
really stable structure and the control
of the e-file and the good light squares
but I agree I like Black's position and
nihal sarin really has shown absolutely
no problems thus far and cranberry's
also down almost for three minutes
impressive speed from nihal sarin and
that's going to be a weapon for him when
you're playing Vladimir kremnik you're
not going to get too many advantages on
the board but I like to position on the
board I like the clock management I
think that kremnik is going to have to
spend some time here and so while he
does maybe we should hop back to our
matchups to start at first nobody back
up musatar of deep into his game against
pankaratov and Levy I saw the chord in
my eye light Square control for white
that's all good and fun except for the
fact this f file is open and that could
also be a problem that white needs to
deal with at some point
but he just moved his Rook to E8 yeah
he's like you know what you're talking
about he's like he's like Robert this is
why I'm playing and you're here you know
what just you just watch my moves and
describe them okay I agree I I to be
honest with you I'm actually shocked by
that move because I don't get where his
other Rook is going is his plan to play
B5 and like
oh well that answers that question
there's no plan to play B5 now
but it looks like it was the plan and
actually I think there was tactical
problems had uh Punk rocks have done
anything else the bishop on D4 needed a
Defender so if we just bring up an
analysis board here uh it would have
seemed so much more natural to play D to
E8 but I think F4 is the problem because
the bishop loses its Defender over here
so you need to be very careful in
positions like this although F4 might
just backfire I mean F4 he takes F4
Queen for F3 check and there's a problem
somewhere yeah F2
there's two's coming and queen F3 with
Maiden so that's a big issue so I guess
the other could have gone to E8 and
that's what I was looking at but on
kratoff has other ideas is about to beat
Another World Champion by the way this
is pretty uh this is pretty sick here I
mean okay he's not much better oh F4 wow
not your back has no respect he's just
like I'm playing this position for a win
and I I think he evaluates that his
chances are are quite strong and he will
sort of figure it out why why does the
computer hate the position that's
something with Rook E6
what what is it and not uh
I don't know espankrative is yeah
pankrative is about to be absorbed by an
alien spaceship of some sort like
it is it's hard not to focus on
the light beaming over his head I I
really I hate this because if he ever
watches the footage back he's gonna be
like man they just insulted me during my
games versus Vichy and they made fun of
my lighting and I just want to say that
we're not Bible we are fascinated and we
are congratulatory and we are in awe of
your performance against Vichy and we
are just enjoying that your camera
lighting looks so bright and beamy and
you know inversed it looks like the
light should be on the other side but uh
I think we're just having a good time
solving good fun
um and uh he's got a great position his
position looks like good fun too look at
the featured chat there Pavel and ding
both ascending into heaven here yeah you
know
looks like the lamp above his head
should be the only light you know
because uh but it's not it's not
um
and my my doggie is aggressively licking
my hand I think he he agrees that uh
pyville is uh you know he's enjoying the
show as well uh the light show and noji
break just has like the perfect overhead
lighting you know just picturesque very
funny yeah actually I'm kind of jealous
of his setup it looks uh very clean you
play chess over there
you play some online chess uh yeah I
think you want to go around I think you
want to go see some other games how's
the niche
yeah let's go to that game and that's
exactly where I wanted to go I think
that nobody has things to figure out and
maybe this is going to liquidate so we
are going to see some trades but Anish
giri is taking on ronak sadwani and look
at this Levy it's exactly what you want
to have happen Okay the F Pawn could
have uh joined the party but there's a
problem for this black king and look at
Rhino's clock
I know I know
the thing at this level is that you can
get the prep okay everybody even the
members of this chat could learn this
candidate's line with black the problem
is once that's over Anish knows 10 more
moves in multiple directions like Anish
has trained he's used stockfish 15 he's
usually he's used you know whatever and
he's looked at various training
positions within the prep even when it's
never been played before he knows the
plans really well and you'll notice he's
down a pawn he's literally down upon his
b-pawn is completely gone so he must
have given it away and offset that with
an attack on the king so obviously he's
got a better grasp of the position and
Robinson I mean he's he's in for it like
this is this is the level difference
right here that's what it takes to get
to that level which is scary because
like you you would think a niche makes
it look so simple he hasn't won the game
yet of course but he makes it look so
simple up to this point it's incredible
how strong they are in the top ten and
the kind of like the the the class that
they demonstrates not just the
preparation however I will say this and
Anisha said this about himself as well
when it comes time for the kill the
critical execution moment of the game
that might be anisha's only kind of like
negative as a chess player like if if he
had that he'd be a full package 28.50
you know but right now it's going to get
to that moment in this game where he's
got to put it away and if he doesn't
Ronald's Gonna Roar back into this game
but the prophet veronic is that some of
these killer moves are kind of obvious
like Knight takes G7 Knight H5 Rook G3
all this kind of stuff looks devastating
for the black king the Knight on C5 is
loose that's very important because this
queen would love to slide on over to
help out the king whether the Knight nc5
will be hangings the D5 Pawn is hanging
you have one minute 35 seconds and
counting down so Anish giri look at him
he is very concentrated I'm a pretty
good friends with a niche we actually
were messaging after he beat Juan June
and you know he was a bit nervous
because he cares a lot about this
tournament and right now look at this
Knight hopping in second one fake
hitting the G3 squared Levy this is
looking worse and worse for aroundex and
wani yeah and in fact on that previous
position the sacrifice of the Knight on
G7
in my understanding of covering a niche
games like that is something that he he
needs to double and triple check whereas
right now where white doesn't need to
sacrifice the Knight anymore probably
and just needs to play Queen G4 G3 this
is the type of position Anish will not
mess up at all like if there's a
position and the only way to push that
Advantage Home is to sacrifice a knight
and go for like a monster king size
attack and each kind of wants to
minimize that danger a little bit here
there's no danger at all there's nothing
to minimize the attack will probably
play itself ronak has 40 seconds and he
makes a move yep it's very difficult to
play with no time and already there are
ideas of The Rook coming to G3 after
this King here and Ryan he looks nervous
I was just gonna say doesn't Queen G4
just at least win upon yes like just at
least because you threatened Knight H6
as well
um
yeah like so right right now Anish looks
a niche looks like he's playing Black
from his face right but he's like oh my
God what a but no it's just like it's
like all right here it is like I know
it's there I know I'm winning I know I'm
winning you just gotta calm myself down
I gotta find that I gotta find that win
Robert let's do the same thing we should
also try to find the win so I mean queen
G4 offhand you should play that move
instantly but not offhand
where's the win
well I'm deliberating between these two
because both look very strong G7 is
under attack and if you protect G7 with
96 the H6 Pawn loses defender on the
sixth rank it's very important so I I
got it one reason I like oh go ahead is
it is it Queen G4 and then G6 Knight H6
and then Knight takes F7 and Rook F3
oh you boom Brook F6 boom get me in this
tournament so I could lose all three
games yes
no but it's forcing and crushing and wow
Anish has the benefit of having so much
extra time that he can sit and think
about this and he has in fact played the
move Queen to G4 so step one no choices
for black here yeah 96 uh I guess is the
other defensive move but it fails I
guess to the same to the same exact
thing not quite though because G7 is
protected
but true
oh gosh 17 seconds for Roundup here he
has no time and he's got no hope this
this is forced your variation will end
it yeah I the re I just wanted to go
forward with the Knight I didn't want to
go back and I think it just in general
for the chat like the way you find that
F7 is you you just have to look at
things that are only guarded by the king
because that's sort of what I like to
it's like Phantom protection just
generally when the king is the only
guarder and the King has to make a move
to defend something it's a waste I mean
it's a very important Tempo and Rook F3
Rook F6 is very very important what a
what an I don't want to jinx anything
but thus far what a dominant game from a
niche and we've seen that when a top
seed does this in game one that
generally it means they're in Peak form
but Sam sevilleon proved that wrong he
got wiped off the board in the first
game after a prep mishap he won that
match against MBL
right and so you're saying we can't
count running out even if he does lose
this game which looks very likely and
you could see a niche super focused and
he I just watch him take his hand away
from his mouth his Mouse excuse me I put
it near the side of his head there so he
is trying not to rush this moment as he
has six plus minutes to 17 seconds so
many people would just try to flag their
opponent here but he doesn't need to win
on time when he recognized the attack is
about to be devastating
yes exactly he he probably did in fact
want to just Blitz out Knight F7 he sees
it the kid the Knight is hanging and it
can either go back or take on F7
uh and taking on F7 right now looks
really appetizing the only thing you're
looking at is counter shots because
losing this game would what with white
is a death sentence you just completely
lose this match you absolutely never get
back into this match so you're right
there you know it's a convincing first
game Anish is going to take his time
here and we'll see if he finds that
knockout punch
yeah I'm just quickly looking at the
other game to see if anything uh as
exciting someone I see that in the human
run yes a panko game somehow there's a
Pawn on C2 so I'm gonna move on to the
vacuum quickly but as soon as the niche
plays Knight takes F7 we can come right
back but how in the world is yes the
bank of a policy too defended by a
knight on D4
uh yeah what
what happened how did we go from Total
what move is this
Okay so yesterday benko spent half the
game copying him and then half the game
just taking over the game
oh my God ding got so frustrated with
the copying he almost repeated moves
yeah he offered a repetition and then
yesterday said no thank you and just
pushed his Pawn forward
wow this is this is this is unreal he
took that that doesn't look right he
allowed yesterday to get a Pawn on C3
wow
this is so weird
and do you sometimes feel like
when a guy has made his career being 28
100 Level Playing a certain set of
openings that doesn't always translate
to another set of openings like that
first round game in in the candidates
against it was in English from dingley
Wren it was Ultra sharp it was not
something he's played his whole career
that doesn't mean you're just 2800
immediately the only player it really
feels like can play positions at 2800
plus level in every opening Robert is
who Magnus Carlson you give that man any
opening somehow
he just knows how to play it look at
this yes the bank was completely turned
the script in this game winning with
black
what in the world that was a very
strange situation and you never see
dingly Wren get phased ever but
something about the way yessa panko
played just the copycat chess it
bothered him and jessupanco has way more
time he has the pawns about to promote
and by the way it needs Geary we're
gonna go back to that game right now
because he has in fact infiltrated
against roundex edwini's King he did
play the move uh not Knight takes F7
Levy Rook F3 which is equally good
because after King H6 Rook takes F7 the
remover F6 was such a big threat with
Queen H4 Checkmate as well so F4 you
can't stop me
yeah this is also very very clean so the
idea was still sacked at night but do it
in a way where the king is not Tangled
among the black pieces that sometimes
can be a bit scary if that black king
was on E7 Zumba that was surrounded by
the Rooks if you don't Checkmate that
King you're just going to be down
tonight but this is not the same
situation all right absolutely nobody is
getting to to that King Anisha still I
love how Anisha is like still thinking
about the difference between King H1 and
King H2 you know like he is really
really handling this professionally and
Raonic resigns dominant first win from
Anish giri
that was as one side of a game as you
can get in the round of 32 so Anish giri
are very impressive to start the day
here
abdusatara and pankaratev have drawn
their first game not too exciting after
the pieces were traded off so that leads
to dingley run who's in trouble it's
been a Vladimir chromics game against
nihal sarin because this position eval
Bar says zeros but of course this is not
just an equal position where there's no
life white has the bishop pair a bishop
that is nicely protected on D5 but
Black's position the pawn structure is
still very solid
very solid and we've gone from nihal
being up three minutes to down two and a
half now nehal is one of these guys that
two minutes on the clock doesn't mean
anything it's an eternity when nehal is
playing he's just gonna make every move
and he might get into time trouble but
somehow he will play very very well in
that time trouble I I kind of get the
feeling Robert that we're getting to
this point in this game where kramnik is
actually the one asking all the
questions but I think black is very
solid I mean I think black's position
answers all of the questions if the
position speaks for itself
it does actually and I have to give a
quick shout out to that move that just
happened here with Queen C8
you know how many people would make that
move it's the best move but not many
people would be willing to retreat with
their Queen when it doesn't even look
like white has a threat but he does
Bishop F4 was kromix threat removing the
Rook from the D file to open up problems
for this black queen so the queen just
slides back protects the bishop that
means that this Knight can hop on over
towards the center of the board instead
of having to go to A5 just to protect
the bishop so I love the move Queen C8
by Neil yeah sometimes in chess you just
have to play defense and that's what
he's doing right now there's everything
in Black's position as guarded
everything you could argue the same
thing about White's position but that's
not really the point White's position is
not under any sort of attack I love the
move E4 by the way it's a very
frustrating position for black it feels
like just feels like you can't move a
whole lot uh and now of course I have
not made a career on improving my
position from this point forward and
trying to win it but time is ticking 140
on the clock is very dangerous and we
just saw romwicks and wani make a fatal
error from a position that was
unpleasant but not completely lost and
okay nihal plays Knight E7 you said this
a long time ago Robert if the light
squared bishops get off the board you
like black right because no Bishop pair
anymore
love Black's tradition if these Bishops
are traded here and the the movie E4
it's very committal you've left behind
some light squares like F3 and the E4
Pawn will be a Target if you don't take
on B7 watch out for C6 your Bishop will
just get trapped over here so krummick
needs a move thankfully if you're think
of it from his perspective he's 320 on
the clock so Levy it's a really big
moment for Vladimir yeah it's a very
very big moment for him to decide what
to do he does in fact trade
and the dangerous thing about his
position with the c and e pawns is that
they look alright but you might have to
resort to things like F3 okay he trades
the Rooks and I guess he's just okay are
we very quickly headed for us Mass
simplification here or can white people
push
I mean I'll do that so quickly I was
watching Vladimir make the moves and
then he's back on the clock so
I feel like black should be happy here
though I mean I always look at the
Knight versus Bishop Dynamic and C5
played not out of any aggressive
intentions but really just to get rid of
a weakness but I just have the sense
that if pieces are traded off Levy we
could get a two on one over here on the
queen side and that could be difficult
for white to deal with oh interesting
yeah I was gonna I was gonna say if
Blackboard to take that pawn many people
might be confused it is a free Pawn but
it breaks her structure completely and
it turns into a game where white will
try to win back the C pawns and
ultimately have a better end game
because that Bishop versus night end
game with symmetrical structure very
winnable for white especially if you get
your king involved we just saw yesterday
Magnus Carlson do this to uh Vincent
kaimer uh in the semi in their
semi-final match uh not in this event we
don't just have surprise magnets in this
event we'd love to maybe next year but
that was what he did I mean he just put
the grind on him with the with the
bishop versus knight and an overall kind
of balanced Pawn structure but nihal is
defending and the time is getting even
but I just want to say like how are we
not in awe right now we are watching one
of the greatest players of the last 30
years play in our online Global
Championship like this is amazing this
is I'm like kind of Blown Away you know
like Nicholas nehal yes he's amazing but
Vladimir kramnik defeated Kasparov there
is a timeline where if that doesn't
happen because part of his world
champion for like 30 40 years like I
mean this man took down the goat I don't
know Robert I'm I'm having a little uh
Starstruck moment no I I think we all
should we we can't take it for granted
that this guy defeated Kasparov who
seemed Invincible at the time but
Vladimir krummick he is very capable not
just of past success but of present as
well he may be retired from Over the
brook classical but he's determined look
at him right now like the way he's
playing this game the way he's searching
the position but nihal yeah the guy
fears nobody Levy and and he's here
calculating he actually has more time
than chromic he has a a few seconds more
than chronic does that is not good for
the former world champion no it's not
and this is this is exactly the danger
against guys like raonica and guys like
nihal for them this is now a bullet game
like you just you literally both have
one minute with the bonus time it does
feel like Blitz but this is a bullet
game what do you need in a bullet game
you need a safe King you need an attack
and you need a knife and he has all of
that and you need Youth and he has all
of that he's got the reaction time he
probably has the better Mouse skills
he's got the horse and he's got an
attack on the king and kramnik can still
hold at make no mistake but it could
Trend very quickly in the other
direction because those light squares
right that's the problem
wow and four that's a good move it
restricts the night but oh my gosh
that's scary yeah that's a difficult
move to play when your king is the one
that looks like it gets more in more
danger H3 at some point watch out for
this queen walking its way in the light
squares and the long term two on one on
the outside part of the board that could
be a nice decoy that white will have to
deal with yep
yep yep yep you did mention it's exactly
what you said two on one see right now
it just sort of feels like white is
playing moves to anticipate what black
is going to do but that Knight is being
very thoroughly restricted which is
which is very important they might get
to a spot where there's nothing black
can sort of do uh you want to check in
on ding so I saw you uh you were
hovering but this game is also very
intense yeah I was just trying to see
what was going on there still looks very
bad for dink so we'll stay here for now
just because we're getting into time
trouble uh of course we can analyze the
dingler and yes the panko game
afterwards there will be more in all of
these matches but look at krumnik down
uh just above a minute on the clock he's
keeping the pace he actually is quite
impressive right now on terms of time
man I don't like that move I don't know
why nehal did that to to get hit with
Tempo I get I get it was very tough
there he had to make a queen move that
also allowed the Knight to get to D7 but
probably this will oh but the Knight is
maybe going to C5 not E5
yeah and watch out because these pawns
are on light squares you move upon to E5
the F5 Pawn comes loose so this is a big
moment for kremnik he cannot afford to
lose this game to nihal sarin he plays
E5 check on the light Square Knight C5
next
oh yeah this is a dangerous dangerous
spot
dangerous spot for kramnik and nihal is
not going to trade pieces and try to
hold any end game or win an end game I
think he's going to keep Queens on but
what do I know 20 seconds on the clock
he might
the good news about this situation if he
played trade in 93 is the bishop
couldn't move because the E5 Palm was
loose but you were 100 correct he's
going after this F5 pawn and chronic
down to 35 seconds he's ahead in the
clock Levy but I think we both are
acting with uh like nihals ahead on time
yeah we are wow E6 I mean Vlad I kind of
like the idea but
I don't know what white was so I don't
know what black was supposed to do there
instead I saw stockfish was basically
laughing at
White's position going forward so much
Queen D5 it's such a sharp position oh
my God great move G5 no checks in the
f-file for the White Queen otherwise the
black king would be mated so now he can
go forward but A7 is under attack he's
just gonna push his pawns over here
Bishop C7 or Bishop A7
Queen age wow
and that trades queens and King E7 King
takes E6
oh man king G2 King F3 probably
it's barely better for black but this
looks very tough for white to my eyes
well if if white was the one up upon it
would be game over because it would be
Bishop Knight right but in this case the
the bishop is very powerful ultimately
if it gets down to one pawn and just the
bishop on the board the bishop will
sacrifice itself but that's not what's
gonna happen
I mean that's a great move
beautiful geometry the a pawn can't move
the Knight can't move but here comes the
king yep is there anywhere to go with it
though yeah I think if white plays
Bishop E7 and A3 that might be
or you gotta I guess you gotta bring the
king wait he uh-oh he wants G5
yeah I don't think I don't think he can
lose that pawn
there's before before one square closer
to promotion now Knight C3 takes A2 is
more threatening nine seconds for
krumnik he plays the best move king of
three best but that's ridiculousness
crazy oh my gosh
still playing the best move Bishop A5
trying to get up for this B4 pawn and
the king is getting closer
this is so dangerous for kramnik with
the knight in 10 seconds but nehal also
four seconds on the clock the night the
Knight can't move
okay with the f
King can help out over here Bishop d8
yeah the Palms lost he lost the pawn
uh he's going to take G4 he can always
trade off over here so you can never
lose this game that's the good news but
he's going for the win King A3 King A2
oh my gosh no but Bishop B7 he has
Bishop B7 I think Bishop B7 A5 bishop d8
and then A4 and then Bishop back to E7
yes
yes and he takes the pawn he just
doesn't want to lose this game yep
yep
he's gonna go right back and paralyze
the position yeah but should be seven oh
what a first game
Kings left on the board
what amazing technique by the both of
them the fact that the evaluation bar
stayed between something like minus
point three and minus 0.7 thereabouts is
unbelievable given how complicated that
ending was I think that was one of the
best and most evenly matched games that
we've seen thus far in the round of 32.
I don't think either side like ever had
much of an advantage in that game unlike
this game
oh my God what happened to that Queen
sash I just
I'm telling you like sometimes I I just
get sad because dingley Wren is a Savage
with the Catalan and these Mainline d4s
but sometimes these these English is
just they just hurt yesterday panko with
a with a massive massive win he was an
eight percent vote before this matchup
who lets these people vote
[Laughter]
what a convincing game from yesterday
panko my goodness oh well the
predictions were not accurate at least
for game one but we see that two players
have a lead in each Geary uh and Andre
yesapanko had demolitions they just
crushed their opponents in game one
Geary the heavy favorite by rating had
the white pieces but yes a panko with
black against dingley Ren wake me up
pinch me how did that happen yeah that's
unbelievable we we hadn't even really
done a
deep dive onto that game we sort of left
them during Symmetry and by the time we
had returned Jessica had a completely
crushing position so we're gonna try to
follow all the games evenly uh but so
far today in our round of 32 matchups
we've seen two very very convincing
victories and two very decently
hard-fought draws we're gonna take a
short break and when we return we will
have the continuation of the round of 32
here in the chess.com Global
championship
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
games of these round of 32 matchups are
done with and we had two impressive
Victors Anish giri and Andre yesapenko
and Andrea sapenko he's a player he's
known around the world for beating
Magnus Carlson that was maybe his
biggest achievement and his most recent
achievement well he's a semi-finalist
and the air things Masters he's a very
very tough opponent for everyone around
the globe and here is a player profile
on him
no stranger to making a good first
impression Andre yesapenko had his hello
world moment at the turn of last year
competing at the prestigious Tata steel
tournament yes a panko managed a
shocking victory over the reigning world
champion Magnus Carlson it is just
groundbreaking one of the only players
who have a winning record against Magnus
Carlson
only 18 at the time yasepenko made
history as the youngest player to hand
Carlson a defeat in a classical game
during his world championship reign
18 year old Andre jessupenco just beat
the world champion in a classical game
wow
late summer the teen sensation had saved
plenty of Mojo for competing in one of
the final opportunities to qualify for
the cgc
oh man he's got quite the mouse
showing the gears on his bike there
dominating his play in session yesapenko
won six of his nine games including
three draws to take first place and
punch his ticket to the round of 64.
despite his age and lack of experience
compared to other veterans in his group
yassipenko has every reason to believe
he can earn a seat at the table in
Toronto this November
asapinco that young man is very well
known and very dangerous and fast time
controls in the community spoke 80
percent of people think he's going to
move on
Levy we heard it from Donya the yessa
panko he qualified down the stretch of
the play in phase and he earned his
right to take on first basem Amin who he
just dispatched of with seeming ease and
now he's taking on dingley Ren here
yesterday Bank was amazing he was
actually touted by a lot of the older
heads in Russian chess as kind of the
guy there's always a batch of players
who are in a certain age group from a
country and Jesse panko was that guy and
we'll see obviously careers have ups and
downs he's been at I think as high as 27
20 maybe 27 30 over the board he's down
now a little bit
but I think over time the skill the hard
work and the Good Fortune the three
things that you need to succeed all
going to line up and we can see some
great things from him that's already
happening that first game that he just
had he won effortlessly with the black
pieces over dingly Wren and dingly ren
is
folks this man is playing for the World
Chess Championship like did you do we
realize who we're watching this is the
amazing thing about the chess.com Global
Championship dingley wren a year from
now might be the world champion of chess
the world champion he might literally be
the best player right I mean we might
have to we can debate Magnus Carlsen
best player world champion best player
sure we're not going to open that
Pandora's box right now but Andre
isafenko just made it look easy now what
I'm wondering is when you win with black
what does that mean for when you play
with white what are we gonna see we're
gonna see him play solid are we gonna
see dingley Wren go for the kill here
with black are we just gonna see him do
normal stuff E6 and
kind of take what comes what comes his
way I think dingley run is not the type
of player who unnecessarily takes risks
he often uh just plays his main stuff
he's not playing the king's Indian for a
must win scenario but I think the first
thing we need to mention Levy is that
yesapago played D4 remember that game
where he beat Magnus Carlson that was a
sicilian he put E4 in that game so he
won game one he chooses D4 likely to
have less combative positions
yeah this one is a queen's indian-esque
position with A3 no Bishop B4 for black
I don't really know what jesupengo's
thinking about here because I'm pretty
sure the only move is cd5 but maybe he's
just remembering his lines
he goes oh Quincy too
I've never seen that move but I mean of
course the idea is dce4 but
what about just C5 here from black just
natural move
well perhaps Andre is in a situation
where he feels like if I can just trade
off pieces and make an equal game he'll
do it because now the onus is completely
on dingly Wren to win probably not this
game but game three and that's so much
pressure for player even if you're the
second highest rated player in the world
it's not easy winning with black is is
not easy oftentimes to win with black at
this level you have to be losing with
black first you have to play an opening
that is just objectively not good but
then as your opponent tries to deal with
that bad opening like a modern defense
right modern Defense computer laughs at
it at this sort of level but
we're really gonna see dingley Wren play
G6 I mean I can't imagine so Queen C2
and they're already thinking what's he
thinking about maybe is he thinking DC
and C5 is he thinking Bishop B7 I'm not
sure what he's thinking about Queen C2 I
guess this is a rare move I'd be playing
a quick Bishop E7 because I do not want
to see this Pawn Lane on e4 uh that's
just bothering me why would I want to
hand the center over and you're gonna
lose C4 next maybe there's a concrete
way to get out of that with C5 as you've
been mentioning but Bishop E7 kind of
keeps the status quo allows you to
Castle C5 in the future will in fact be
played but he does take on C4 Maybe
it's somewhere deep in his files or he
fuels the burden of the match score
exactly but the thing is if you play for
a win now it could just be all over
that's that's the problem I mean to nil
we haven't seen a comeback this year
from two nil
and okay one matchup I remember was
close to us wow B5
okay we see the point right that the
Knight is very useful here defending the
pawn but this is dingley red taking
risks yeah I guess this is how ding does
it I'm Knight takes B5 and then the C4
Pawn also falls but this is the way he's
looking to create imbalance
right give me these two I'll give E4
remember that black is currently up a
pawn so it'd be even material at the end
of that so dingly Ren he shows no fear
and Andre yesapenko has to prove that uh
what he's done is complete justifiable
he plays E5 but now it's kind of
transposed in a way right Levy we see
these types of positions in a different
move order where you give up the B5 Pawn
your Pawn structure looks terrible but
with the Knight on B6 and this wonderful
Bishop on B7 now black really does have
good chances
yes
there's Knight takes B5 indeed
the chances are definitely
definitely there for black they're so
subtle though and that this is the kind
of player that dingley run is he doesn't
need much he doesn't need some barreling
King side attack he just needs
a slight
slight
didn't just structural kind of a thing
overextended Pawn on E5 or something
like that
what that's holding needs and if he's
unable to get a winning opportunity from
this game okay no problem he'll just
play kind of a balanced game of chess I
feel like all of our games have started
right
you have yes since let's go to the game
between Anish giri and Radix and wani
because ronak he's needing a win with
the white pieces uh but playing this the
white side against a super Grand Master
was so locked up he does make this move
Rook to B1 his attentions to play B4 go
after this Pawn would be seven but I
have to imagine that Anish giri is not
one bit displeased to be where we are
right now
no I I completely agree this looks
actually visually looks amazing for
white looks like white has more space
white has active pieces white has good
control of the black position
but this is just kind of the russellimo
right this was a russellimo no light
squared Bishop doubled C pawns must have
been a russellimo what line of the
rosalimo was it
that's a good question we can quickly
scroll through the moves it was it's
been all the rage go cash pragnanda they
played this from the black side E5 just
to stop this move d4 in its tracks and
so Bishop takes and then A4 so gaining
some space bringing the Knight around to
the C4 Square so all these moves are
standard the Knight comes back to E8 to
allow black to
improve the location try to go to D4 and
so this maneuvering is standard
feels like the russellimo surged in
popularity since Magnus Fabiano right
just yes exploded like I I almost don't
remember it being
trendy at top level at all it was kind
of like some weird exotic line
uh but now ever since that match World
Championship in London
seems like it's just it's almost the
main line in fact because you just don't
want to enter the sashnikov you don't
want to answer any of that stuff against
a very well prepared opponent I did not
know that Anish giri has this in his
toolbox
legitimately had no idea like what was
he going to play was he going to play an
accelerated Dragon what was he gonna
play was he gonna play as fashnikov
uh that's a great question maybe Raonic
will have to test that out in game four
but right now I love Black's position
you have
ensured that D4 is not happening now
your Bishop can just sit on C6 so B7 is
not loose and I I don't see a single
issue in Black's Camp here you could
play Bishop C6 Rook D7 Rook d8 I'm
starting to like this position for a
niche
if yeah if black can play B5 like if
black can move the queen side pawns
black is just going to be in great shape
Black Will and then black will also play
a five that's another thing that we are
patiently waiting for potentially when
is Black going to play F5 if black plays
F5 and it works White's in trouble the
center is going to fall apart
but right now luckily that is not
possible it depends who you're cheering
for but it's not possible I agree though
where does Relic move his Rook B1 B3
I guess he he wants to increase the
pressure here
you need to play C4 and Knight to D5 you
know what I mean like you need to be
able to do that but that requires you to
move your bishop and then move your
knight to E3 then play C4 it's very time
consuming yeah but I don't know if black
has time to punish it either so I would
be considering that otherwise I
don't really know what white does well
if you play Bishop D2 the second you
play Knight E3 I guess I play Knight F4
right and then
and then
yeah I mean not only do I stop Knight D5
I I also attack D3 and position looks
just amazing that was like a very
important idea for white and it's just
it seems impossible
and by the way what's stopping Rook D7
and Rook d8 that was my first instinct I
I think that it might be a bishop move
in Knight E3 because if you can get this
Pawn of C4 and clog the D file let's
just show some uh some moves here just
so we can give everybody a clearer
illustration of what we're talking about
like let's say Bishop C1 I know it's not
a good move but if you just kind of
nonchalantly go with your Rooks doubling
then this Knight gets to D5 and that's
why the Rook is on B3 so that D3 is
defended and let's say I make another
kind of random move and in comes my
knight to D5 now I'm starting to feel
much better about White's chances
exactly then you control the center F5
now is no longer as scary because
there's no Knight on E3 to be attacked
with F4 and then your your queen side
prospects also increase because you kind
of control the center unfortunately
we've just given white like four moves
in a row
someone tells me that a niche giri will
not take lightly to that no no no he uh
will be able to put pressure on the D3
Pawn very quickly so as soon as this
bishop moves you can play Queen D7 and
go right for the pawn what are you gonna
play Knight E1 all your pieces going in
the wrong direction uh yeah I think that
Anish has nothing to worry about and
Raonic he'll spend some time here trying
to come up with a plan so maybe we can
move on to uh some of the games we
haven't looked at yeah for example Abdul
sitarov and pankurata we've got just an
amazing assortment of games today
what a game what is the what is going on
here what if what is this opening some
weird nimso Indian what was this Casa
Corley where you at this that's what I
think about when I see these nights like
this
oh that was that Queen's Gambit game
yeah
yes was that it
uh I don't remember the exact variation
that led us to that famous tactical game
but it looks like it A5 was the line A5
Knight A6 yup
oh hey oh same similar thing right the
night coming to E6 via f8 rather than C7
yeah this
pretty much looks like it to my eyes
yeah except in that game I think black
had still had the light score Bishop
somehow and managed to sacrifice and
then open up the position but
yeah either way though what's up with
these pawns feels like black is
everything you could possibly ask for
here
just clear pressure yep
oh
that's annoying
d5's hanging
D5 is hanging and E4 is coming by the
way like maybe not right now because d e
is at least possible but also H4 at some
Moment Like The Knight has to go
somewhere Queen C5 wow
I'm so bad at these positions there's so
many different combinations of captures
and tactics like what is the move here
for white what do you play here
I would be surprised if Knight takes D5
just leads to a better position uh the
one problem that white will have to deal
with is this outside pass Pawn that is
already a runner but with a bishop
against the Knight let's say we just go
through a situation like this where we
get here maybe black should keep the
Queens on but let's say you don't and
you get here
all of a sudden white can push E4 the
bishop will become very strong this Rook
will just come to A1 to stop this Pawn
The Rook on D5 May land on D7 white has
the more promising position
for sure that almost so my eyes after E4
B6 Rook D7 it just looks completely
winning for white I don't even
understand why it how it possibly can't
be just looks amazing but of course
computer always knows best yeah so
there's no point even using our brain
for some reason it's not totally winning
I think we're gonna see something just
like this Knight takes D5 has been
played by pancratov and the fact that
Nordic hasn't immediately taken on D5
kind of indicates to me that he is not
happy about his position because what
else are you going to do you just lost
upon the center these Knights are
staring at each other you have to take
on D5 and now he does but I feel like
he's worried about the direction this
end game is going and that's why he
might take with the queen here yeah
yeah
oh
what he doesn't even take what
B6
what you I just don't he's not a pawn
there's a B6 instantly wow I did did he
forget about Rook A5
where was what was that
they're nice protected right we're not
missing that
yeah I guess he just
that was really that was really
surprising because B6 was your plan
anyway you can easily protect that which
is what you want to do because A4 so
maybe he's trying to hold on cling to
this outside pass Pawn as a way to get
competition Rook a five a great move as
well
yeah you played B6 you might as well go
for the a pawn right this is crazy we're
actually getting to that end game except
black is already down a pawn Rook 8 Rook
A7 looks like a huge problem you do not
want to take that rook and allow a Pawn
on A7 yep you definitely don't want to
allow a pawn that far that can also be
anchored by the bishop so there's E3 E4
and structurally speaking
black is just almost com I think his
black is just on the verge of being
completely lost so what I what I was
just mentioning what Nordic needs to do
somehow don't know how I can do this
trade off these four pawns beat down a
Pawn on the king side because Knight's
short range pieces they're much happier
when all the pawns are on the same side
of the board but with pawns both sides
of the board that's good for the bishop
so somehow I don't know how he's gonna
do it but like Rook C3 Rook A4 and then
get this B6 Pawn maybe Knight C5 and go
for it but I'm not liking the direction
of this game for the world rapid
Champion yeah me neither I don't know
what's going on at all here
so something's going terribly wrong
he just has nothing
I don't know I he his best case scenario
is somehow getting into an end game
where he's a pawn down on the same side
right that's like the one way he will
hold this but if you're a pawn down on
the opposite side
good night you're not especially if it's
a pass Pawn like you're not holding it's
not especially not in Bishop versus
night situation so
so maybe eventually he wants just to
freeze white with Brooks coming down to
the second rank that could be an issue
but this Rook on A7 is keeping the Rook
on D7 honest this is not going to be fun
even if ultimately he holds this game
it's gonna take a lot of work and
pancreat of playing some great chess
here in the cgc but let's keep moving I
quickly want to show the update of the
dingley ren game against Andrea sapenko
and then we'll go to nihal Saron against
Vladimir kramnik because we haven't seen
it but I just have the corner in mind I
saw this position Levy and I felt like
Black's kind of playing checkers here
with all these pieces
wow but this is like Kind of Perfect
right this is like a perfect uh
setup for trying to play a position for
a win at the highest level of Chess you
gotta you gotta just play some Checkers
sometimes
are you playing checkers on playing
chess no I'm I'm actually playing
checkers uh
like I like this position for for ding
from the standpoint of pressure on the B
file in good control of the center what
I am worried about is the fact that his
entire Army of pieces is designed to
break through in B2 and if it doesn't
white can go F4 G4 F5 checkmate
and
that is a problem
huge problem defense who you're cheating
for again if you're cheering for one guy
maybe not
well I think we're just trying to toggle
positions oh this king is Stranded by
itself and don't be surprised if uh
White starts bringing pieces over this
way a rook lift at some moment so
dingley Ren is all in on the queen side
he's feeling the pressure of being down
a point and now we'll see if yesapenko
goes for the king side this lonely King
over here could be in some trouble but I
did promise we go to krumnik against
nihal sarin so I'm just gonna bring this
over there it may not be the most
fascinating of positions right now in a
maroxy bind structure but nihal slightly
better as white typically is in the bind
Robert I'm listen I'm I'm terribly sorry
I really do enjoy uh waking up and doing
these shows but my dog is aggressively
pawing at my hand and putting his face
like directly it's it's adorable it's
I'm sorry like this chest is great this
event is awesome you're awesome but I I
can't I I can't I'm like snapping photos
here to send to my wife of how adorable
this bozo is you have any pets Robert
no no you want a pet I love dogs love
cats you know I I mean I think
yeah I would prefer to have a dog but I
don't know why people are so anti-cat
never made sense to me why don't you
have what why don't you have a dog then
if you want if you could have a dog well
I you know not always here so that's
part of the problem
yeah but you know you bring bring them
to our place well dog sit
I get it I feel like you know you know
the other thing is like raising a dog in
New York City is tough yeah I feel like
a dog needs a field yeah and uh you know
you don't got a lot of fields here ain't
a lot of fields so no that's for sure
but you know your dog seems happy so
he's uh he he he's he's all right
[Music]
um
yeah well he's I mean he's an adorable
Bozo but the the secrets to pet
ownership is having like you know six or
seven loving nicknames and six or seven
derogatory ones
well I thought Rook D6 was just a free
Pawn for a second I guess there's some
trick some if E4 is hanging at the end I
guess
yep
um but there are some tactics because
this Knight and F6 is loose so
if this night's out of the way the
Knight and F6 can be captured so even to
move like Knight D5 somehow comes to my
mind I don't think it's necessarily good
but I'm just trying to figure out the
tactics on this diagonal
yeah I'm also trying to figure out the
tactics on this diagonal these guys are
having some super positional games last
time it was like a very modern structure
doubled C pawns uh this this game is
Hedgehog it's English Hedgehog or like
maroxy kind of game
very complicated stuff here very very
interesting positional battle between
these two
I can read between those lines though
you're like very interesting battle
between these two but I don't want to
look at this closed position for now
because the other games
I I said No Such Thing your honor um
we're gonna but uh I'm taking us away
because Anish giri against ranak sidwani
is really heating up so a Black's King
side in that game wide open but look at
the evaluation part black is much better
despite this King being a little open
the reason why is I saw this position
and I thought Queen H5 was good didn't
when the board was very small recognize
the Rook is on B3 and on B1 so you Queen
cannot jump over here the rook and E1 is
hanging
the board ended up opening up and not in
the way that Ronald saidwani would have
liked
because his pieces are super scattered
and not equipped to deal with the and B5
is still always coming like that's
that's always the problem
but this bishop on C6 is a beast it
protects B7 which was your main problem
and now it puts pressure on G2 I think
that black could probably kick this
Knight because your best move is Knight
F3 and you can consider capturing but
with the bishop pair here Levy the open
e-file under blacks control
and Bishops oh Queen G7
yep the show of six Queen G7 and what a
game from a niche just really really
sharp play so far
positional mixing it in with a
little bit a little bit of spice a
little bit of Checkmate threat
wow this is really not looking good for
running he has to just make quick moves
I feel like the only chance he has is to
somehow put a niche in some time travel
uh but he's
oh here it comes
oh gosh
oh you stopped us
what an amazing position and that F Pawn
wall F5 F4 just not allowing any of
White's pieces through
I kind of feel for Veronica I mean he
just showed up and he's just getting
blown off the board
yeah this is this is awesome just
putting your pieces here it's very
straightforward as you call them the
pieces are scattered they're not helping
out on this King side and with all of
Black's pieces about to hunt this white
king I feel like Anish is well on his
way to a second shoot but you see wrong
shaking his head he's like no this is
this ain't for me I gotta get something
going here uh but yeah the position is
really bad yup
I I feel for him what of convincing uh
first round matchup against
to paulov
but now he shows up to play in each giri
who had a not maybe didn't have some
crazy dominant display despite being the
one seed in the group but
like look at this this is not even
it's not even remotely close right now
what Raonic has to do what he did wrong
in that first game
besides losing in like 25 moves that
happens but he got to 40 seconds and he
made a fatal mistake so right now his
time is ticking but if he keeps at it
keeps at it stays focused maintains
decent time balance he could be okay
Anisha is also human he can make
mistakes if he gets low on time but
not 40 seconds low on time for white so
ronix Gotta Move
no it's hard to even make a move because
you've seen the threats that are coming
and they seem Unstoppable I'm just going
to take us around the horn a little bit
just because we do have four games going
on at once I'm quickly gonna flash this
game and I'm not gonna stay here I'm
gonna go to the game between yes to
Panko and dingley Wren I just want to
show that black is no longer down upon
so not really anything to worry about
right now for Abu satara in fact what
this bee Pawn maybe he can even start
thinking about a win so we'll come back
to see how this happened but I do want
to focus our energy on the game between
dingley Ren and Andre yesapenko because
dingley Wren wants to strike back with
the black pieces and here we see the
checkers game continues the B file is
open the king side pressure is there
Levy three minutes 30 seconds for
yesapenko I'm starting to like dingley
wren's position more and more
yeah me too me too this is a tough spot
for yessipenko because he's gonna are we
just gonna get her a position what's
going on here I don't think England's
gonna repeat I don't think he should
repeat
yeah
you hyped it up man I was getting
excited
[Laughter]
then all of a sudden
yeah he can repeat right the point is
that after King G8 to protect F7 this
Queen's coming to G3 to pin the pawn on
G7 and threat Bishop H6 so what are the
moves come to mind Levy there's no
threat immediately that I see oh no come
on dang don't do this
yeah Dane come on man
oh wow even he looks disappointed in
himself but he's making the moves
oh gosh well the game is officially over
to draw yesapanco keeps his lead but in
this position there was no immediate
threat Levy so I was thinking that black
could perhaps try to dump on the B file
I don't know what White's threat was
maybe there's G4 G5 at some moment but
that looks risky so dingley red he does
the Super Jam thing let me just make a
draw with black and try to win with
white but trying to win his white in
game one did not work out
yep
oh all right we got one more game
wait theoretically he has two more games
but you know who doesn't have two more
games
yeah he literally does have two more
games because he can win two rapid games
and first Armageddon
but uh
Anish giri is looking like the most
convincing
gentleman to uh advance to the round of
16 playing like this he's gonna be tough
to beat
and I don't think that he was one of the
favorites by the community predictions
uh throughout anything Abdul sitarov in
many people's brackets were and that was
the pick to take down a niche in the
next round we don't even know if uh
Nordy back will make it through pankrato
who's playing great chess here but Anish
giri second game in a row where he has
the upper hand feels like there's no
real way to go wrong for black when you
have this kind of attack
yeah I I have to say this is I I mean I
I really hope I am correct I don't
remember and my brain hasn't exactly
turned on but I predicted giri knows
you're back and then I I basically said
obviously the winner
uh that's going to be the final I I
don't I don't know who I have in the
winter there it's obviously about 50 50.
but playing like this is going to be
really really tough uh to beat a
nishikiri and noji break has not been as
convincing today although he has
storm back against which did not make
any sense let me know Bishop two and F3
91 Rook takes E1 and you can't stop mate
along the G file so Knight E3 would be
the way to continue this position and
you can't take on E3 because of f take
T3 and the queen protects the second
rank I'm just gonna show that quickly we
don't need to now support uh or actually
the Knight is also protecting it but
Pawn takes and the queen covers somehow
this is even love positions like this G3
probably right yeah yeah but uh just to
show everyone as well 91 Rook takes you
one is nasty if the queen takes Queen G2
is Checkmate so if the king takes Queen
G1 is Checkmate the king Is No Escape
score because the queen is in the way so
what is the move Levy you found a great
tactic earlier in game one in this match
after Knight G1 two G2 to E3 is just
Rook to G8 and the average eight King E1
and maybe
Queen G1 Knight F1 Rook back to E8 93
Bishop H4 something like that some
completely ridiculous
so
G2 Bishop H4 oh there's also just F4 oh
my God
oh my God how many pins does a super GM
need to win a game oh my God this is so
miserable
I can't even look at it anymore yeah
this is disgusting what
ah it's like the worst position I've
ever seen you just can't move any pieces
no and Anish is just feeling it Bishop
takes G2 check wasn't the only way to
have a huge Advantage but oh my gosh he
doesn't even take the Knight he just got
Queen H6 and the Knight of e3 is pinned
another pin
wow I'm loving this I'm loving this
Anish I don't know I don't know what
kind of pep talk he got you know from
his kids from his wife I don't know what
he ate but he's uh he showed up
and and he's taken he's taking Roundup
around the block I mean this is not uh
this is not good Rhonda's got one minute
and to be honest with you I'm kind of
glad he only has one more minute we only
have to look at this position for one
more minute because uh this is sad man
this is
this is rough romwick's face is like
he's not even his face is not even like
what's going Robin's not even playing
that bad and each Geary is just full
Savage mode all right look at Anish he
is so determined right he has been
staring at the position he hasn't been
looking around he has not been
distracted he's been moving his hand
away from the mouse and I think that's
actually very good for him because it
allows him to settle into the position
rather than rushing his choices he's
been ahead in the clock in both games
thus far Levy this is a kind of like a
new Anish giri from what I've seen and
it's scary
yeah it's definitely scary now probably
just F takes G2 hunt the king out
Gucci Queen H4 you still got to be
precise it's the problem
still got to be precise
Ronald's like bro what did I do to you
take it easy oh my God
and Anish is not taking easy on an FJ G2
looks great
yeah the thing is you you actually still
have to be a bit careful like if the
thing about attacks is that oh my God he
just takes the pawn he just doesn't even
get look at this he doesn't even care
he's using this Pawn to try to deliver
checkmate
he should play Bishop takes F2
does that work can you still play Bishop
F2 or do you okay just no I don't even
want to no F takes you too simple he's
gonna play Bishop G3
yo finish plays Bishop G3 I mean I mean
that's just
that's so rude
oh my God that's probably the best move
by the way I think he's playing Bishop
G3 because Queen H1 is mate and if you
take oh my God you lose your queen over
here Bishop G3
and then if King G1 oh oh it's the
resignation and roundic just runs away
he can't even look at the chessboard
anymore and what a game from anishkiri
oh my gosh Anish giri I I almost wish
that was like the deciding game it's
kind of a shame we have to even get him
back here like can we just can we have a
mercy rule like just no listen we got to
respect our competitors it's two nothing
that's really that's really the thing
it's it's not over ronic does have a
chance to to win but oh my gosh and
noribbeck Abdus won that game
yo this is why this man is the world
rapid champion because I thought he was
busted what happened can we go back to
move 29 where black is just down a pawn
what how did Black win this game
let's see where the mistake happened
Rook seats okay so he just lost his B6
Pawn
why why did he do that why did what okay
can we
well Robert why he play H4 what are you
doing like what why not just E4 here is
there anything wrong with E3 E4 I'm
guessing he just didn't want a knight to
land F4 at some point but he got passive
you can't just sit and do nothing and
then play random kind of Pawn pushes on
the side of the board
that's unbelievable he won an end game
down a pawn so I clicked uh the wrong
space yeah no this is I
pressing the down button to the side
Arrow so he went like this
and now black is a past pawn and that
pawn started moving very quickly
that's unbelievable wow you it's just
crazy F5 check because it's a huge
blender like it looks like a good move
but the problem is that
yeah if you take over here and take on
eat wait sorry this work is hanging I
can't even think anymore
I think nozier bread kind of set that
trap he had a feeling that maybe
pancrata would would play a five yeah
noisy back has one
it's funny because we're expecting the
final to be Geary not your back but the
way norger Beck won we're like in shock
and Anish is just a locomotive it's just
get out of the way but you know chess is
the kind of thing where that doesn't
carry over into the next matchup it's
not like if they play it's going to be
not your back you know praying to the
chess Gods he wins an end game against
the niche down a pawn and otherwise it's
only draws and anisha's not going to
steamroll him it's a match-up thing it I
think a lot of this does have to do with
the fact that giri's openings are Elite
and roundup's openings might be 26.50
and that is a massive difference
right just a massive difference yeah
there's no carryover it's not just uh
what happens in one match will happen
the next but right now this position the
eval bar off the side says zeros and
Vladimir kramnik well ahead on the clock
against nihal sarin but nihal sarin
might lure you into the sense of comfort
and confidence that all is good in
Black's position but he's maybe the best
bullet player on chess.com
mm-hmm
uh well like the best build a player
like when uh when no one else is online
or like when they're also online
oh let's go hyper bullet because it
rains like 3 300. yeah oh that's a great
question who is the best 1-0 player you
gotta go Hikaru right but like Madness
is we we know is this Magnus
tough I don't know
I think in 1-0
straight up I think it's a toss-up uh
maybe maybe they know the answer to that
question but it feels like a car winning
the bull Chess Championship uh you know
that's a pretty good Testament to his
strength and he did so in convincing
fashion but of course Magnuson play but
if you did an arena style like you know
a bunch of guys just going back and
forth and I think if you put it over
like 60 Minutes I Gotta Give the the
advantage in hyper bullet to Daniel
neridiske I think neridisky might be
because I think he just goes
just full Focus
obliteration mode and he has that
tactical style where he'll just grind
you down over the hour and he can't he
could play bullet all night so
um
anyway speaking of
here's another this matchup is so close
and we can't call that ahead of time
that this would definitely be the the
closest one and the most
kind of
the biggest toss-up
and kramnik's like kind of smiling he's
like he's like enjoying himself this is
uh
it's a tough game for kramik tough match
for kramek oh he's just
his time Advantage is gone right that is
out the window and look at me how he's
stretching the guy has 39 seconds left
yeah he should have his hand on his
Mouse and he's like yeah okay my back
needs a little bit of adjustment maybe
I'll see the chiropractor office in Rook
C2 from krumick this queen might come to
E2 next this looks scary for a new home
this does but nihal is is not it's not
prone to massive blunders Under Pressure
but if there's ever a position to
blunder massively it's right now I have
no idea what he should play
that's what I was thinking about you
could potentially even think about Queen
E2 and Rook E6 played we need to the
response watch out that is a Checkmate
thread rookie eight you have to play
Bishop f8
is it Rook G6 then but then King f8
King just runs a bishop fate
what is the idea here
how is this just even
is there
Queenie oh
he gives up the bishop
these two are just so precise in these
complicated moments if it's Knight E5
looks so bad for black but then just
King G7 I guess get out of that pin and
then Bishop D6 D4 is hanging G3 is loose
anyone's game at this point
well rugby three somehow
looks good or Bishop D6 is better I
don't know I like okay plays Bishop D6
freezing this Knight in E5 and now Rook
V3 looks very you go King F6 King F5
oh you would
yeah I didn't like this I didn't I
wanted to keep the king cut off but King
F6 King F5 I would never play it I would
play Rook B3 right but
great great recognition by you and by
nihal he brings the king up immediately
now G3 is not loose and this Knight can
come to D4 B5 is going to be a problem
I like it
yeah we're heading for a position where
white is going to have these broken
pawns egh but that's still a draw
because you just you can't really take
advantage of them but uh if anybody's
pushing uh it's it's maybe black five
eight seconds now
foreign
there somehow okay Knight E7 if you want
to be
super creative or yeah same thing like
beef oh B5 is hanging so this forces to
trade right and then Knight A7 happens
after the pawns captured now where it's
equal and this is why Knights want just
pawns the same side of the board chronic
declined to draw I think he just didn't
see the offer and don't get forked
yeah that would be that that would
definitely be tragic I think I think
kramek's looking for a repetition
yeah he doesn't want any more moral
degradation
well it's never it's never too late for
some good old-fashioned moral
degradation yeah that's the tough thing
here is it's really tougher white to
move also because the pawns are all in
dark squares
chronic is very slow like
okay maybe
this mouse is better than I was giving
credit for
yeah there it is they found the
repetition they will repeat can we see
if King F6 King F5 was the winning idea
let's go to it right around here or what
what was the winning idea what was it so
bad was it
King F6 no apparently not 100 accurate
uh but if we just go back to this moment
could it be F6 even though we're never
supposed to play it
and just take G3 not not guaranteed so I
said Rook A2 instead there it is Rook A2
is better because you don't want the
king out and A3 is hanging and B Force
hanging and G3 is loose
tough yeah that's why he shook his head
I mean one chance you know on move 50
after 30 minutes of a game that's that's
how it goes this matchup is we have
nothing to choose between these guys
like really honestly honestly this has
been so close let's take a look at the
overall scores of the day
as uh every matchup now has had decisive
games with the exception of this one
there's a very good chance this one goes
to the Armageddon there's uh also a
possibility that you know it gets
decided in
games three and four uh Anish giri
Robert just an absolute Savage thus far
two nil and no questions asked there
dingly Ren needs to probably win that
next game with white otherwise he will
take that one point deficit into a game
with black that fourth game of the rapid
and not yet just pulled a rabbit out of
a hat winning an end game down a pawn I
wish I could do that uh we will go on a
short break but before we do that we
actually have uh a a very cool video
here where if you ever wondered who has
won the most prize money in chess over
the course of their career uh you can
think of the biggest names like Carlson
Vichy Kasparov we actually crunched the
numbers
and chess.com published the full
inflation adjusted analysis of all the
championship Super tournaments money
matches and you guys can type
exclamation point Prize winners in the
chat to learn more uh maybe
some point in the future one of y'all
will be on this list
or maybe not but uh we're gonna return
with the third rapid game of all four of
our amazing matchups we've got three
matches that do have a leader but one is
looking like it'll take us to the end of
the day that one between Vladimir
kramnik and the hulsar and don't go
anywhere we'll be right back
foreign
[Music]
open to anyone
all around the world are you kidding me
the chess.com Global Championship offers
the dream of playing against the best
whoa and hey have we mentioned there's
also a million dollars at stake the
total pot is a million dollars no that
it's not a typo the prizes are
unbelievably generous we began with
thousands of players now only dozens
remain you you don't just do this to
shockery are in a critical game except
Alexis Verona just did gorgeous chess he
makes his way into the round of 16.
The cgc Knockout phase has arrived
there are those who played their way in
and some are here thanks to their
well-earned reputations
[Music]
no matter who you are things are about
to get very very real
move on to the round of 16
a trip to the cgc finals and a clean
shot at the largest first place prize of
the year
my friends it's the cgc round of 32. who
will take the next step to Toronto
and we see red ox and wani on screen
here he is down two games to nil he must
win the next two against Anish giri just
to head to Armageddon so I'm Grandmaster
Robert Hess International Master Levy
rosin Levy
two wins in a row against Anish Gary
I don't think so
I also don't think so unfortunately it's
a very very difficult spot for Raonic
but fortunately we don't end matchups on
I don't think so so yeah go home
anisha's gonna qualify I do remember off
the top of my head the only time that in
a best of four somebody came back from
two nil down was actually karyakan in
the World Cup against Peter Fiddler that
was crazy and in fact karyakan was
losing in that third game it got as bad
as it possibly could but we're kind of
starting to see
why 8911 was so lopsided I I kind of
have to apologize to these Community
predictors who I sometimes uh make fun
of when they predict something
ridiculous but there it is we see the
modern defense I mean this is what you
kind of play when you you wow D6 G6 A6
he's not even putting a bishop on G7
he's doing it this way why and he should
play like A4 he should just not let
round like do anything but
here's what you're doing when you want
your when you know your opponent wants
to get wild move ratnick will play the
hippo which I love to play it's
objectively terrible well not terrible
it's a little strong but it's very bad
and white just gains all the space in
the world so we'll see how a niche
responds here because he knows that he
doesn't need to do anything major a draw
wins him the match he could make moves
like H4 he can make A4 he can continue
taking space in addition to essential
pawns white is going to be better but
the good thing for roundic is there's no
Clarity in the position at least not yet
and instead Anish takes a king's Indian
approach
yes so now it's a king's Indian but
black has played the move A6 which is
not always that
useful but it certainly can be but I can
then play B5 or C6 B5 okay Bishop G4
yeah I really like these kind of kings
in the uh ask positions
but uh can't you just play D5 at some
point like yes now
yep and A6 is kind of like a wasted
tempo
yeah you could have developed more
pieces instead your Pawns in A6 and now
you can play E5 but again your Pawn's in
A6 so it feels like you've lost some
very important time and a niche should
be thrilled about his position and he
still looks as focused as ever
I you know you could maybe even play de5
if you really want just be super
annoying I like that decision actually a
lot because D5 is very very
confrontational black plays Bishop takes
okay please D5
that's fine it's fine it's not a bad
move obviously it's certainly the main
move but I like your point D5 because if
you take a E5 with your Pawn you're
offered a queen trade now we're
liquidating I don't think White's in any
danger if you take with the Knight on E5
and we get this kind of position over
here and you can take with the pawn
great Rook to D1 thank you very much for
the time if you take with the bishop
eventually I'll play F4 and castle and
white gains more and more space but look
at this D5 97 very King's Indian like
but you're
at least one tempo behind and probably
more because your Bishop never is on G4
I think the best move here is Knight G1
why there instead of like D2
I don't know I think it's because you
can recapture on E2 with the Knight
I think the night at 92 might also be uh
reasonable yeah but
I think
in many of these King's Indian positions
what people don't realize is Black's
light squared Bishop is the most
important piece yeah he plays C5 he's
not taking the time to be solid he's
he's just playing the best moves and I
think he's able to do this because of
that move A6 that was a very important
Tempo otherwise black might have had a
night out already black might have been
castled so this could just be completely
over in the next seven eight moves
looks really bad now what has the pair
of Bishops and more space and a lead in
development and is never going to be an
attack because as you were mentioned you
need a light Square Bishop so he goes
Bishop H6 and this is not to criticize
roundex play in this game the reason
he's playing like this here is because
of the previous results so he has to try
something and winning with the black
piece against Denise Geary I'd rather I
don't even know like
I don't think I can think of anything
worse
yeah I wonder if here you could just
take H6 and oh well your C5 Pawn is
hanging okay so maybe Queen D2 I was
gonna say H4 H5 but there's no reason to
do that just Queen D2 and
trading Queen D2 and the Knights gotta
move and it's just
very time consuming for black so we uh I
think should go to the other game the
one between dingley Wren and Andre
yesapenko it's underway we'll leave
round x18 to come up with some Dynamic
chances but we are going to switch games
now uh to the Chinese Superstar and his
Russian opponent who's you know in the
lead and what do you make of this
position out of the gates
once again I just absolutely cannot
predict the opening what was this some
sort of F3 nymph so what what was this
I believe that wow
it wasn't f3m so yeah those positions
look like uh bomb exploded in the center
of the board like the and then the
pieces just sort of scatter all over the
place yeah B5 like this is this opening
is not for the this opening is not for
the faint of heart oh my gosh and and
there's so many nuances here it's like
why would you play A6 if you're gonna
take out C4 anyway you are happy that
white commits to A4 because now you've
less control over squares than the B
file so this is a good
situation for black I believe that Sam
Shanklin won a game against certain
kariakin in the World Cup in exactly
this line where black is down a pawn but
has quite a lot of play because Knight
D3 check is already on the table C4
filed by Knight D3 take over the dark
squares you've learned the regret
putting upon F3 so this is some engine
prep this is a line I actually studied
this line with a friend
and he was telling me how he found this
line with black they didn't find it but
if white plays perfectly White's white
is a pawn up and white can actually
apply some pressure but the problem is
playing perfectly with the position like
this is not simple
um and black basically moves the queen
plays Rook d8 Bishop C5 but if you go
wrong here yeah you're right it's that
Shanklin game and if you go wrong you
lose on the spot like it it's over so
uh yeah I think Alina because it's
really funny I think vitashek and Alina
kushlinsky I have both played this and
they're a married couple so uh you know
it's you got you got uh preparation kind
of uh in in one household which is
really which is really funny and I think
they've played it with some success so
um
now Knight H3 I think is the move it's a
very crazy line Queen C5 oh my gosh this
is wild stuff there's one huge downside
to this is because it's engine
preparation if yesapanko knows it all it
might just be immediately equal but I
tend to like challenging your opponent
in theoretical lines where you are gain
a pawn because if they make one mistake
especially in Rapid chest you have to
play more quickly then you have the
upper hand but look at yesapenco go all
of his pieces on good squares we're
coming to d8 this work can then land on
D3 Queen E3 check is perhaps Black's
next move so with the inability Castle
I'm liking yessa panko's position right
now we'll see how ding the Run continues
he is also down on the clock so let's go
to the other games that are just getting
underway nardivek Abdus atarov taking on
pankarat oven you're gonna like the
opening Levy in this one because
pankaratev who is now down one half
plays move H5
what
oh he must have analyzed this during the
break right like he might he must have
because they repeated lines
I'm gonna I'm gonna go check the
database this is uh this is some pretty
good some pretty goofy stuff
wow
H5 and Alpha zero approach let's go H4
let's try to capitalize on the fact that
white fiend kettled so whenever there's
a fan cut or Pawn structure you think
about pushing this one look at this when
you're under attack Sometimes the best
defense is striking in the center with
the move d4
yeah so that position after B3 has been
reached
uh like nearly 700 times by many many
good players
the move H5 happened once and it was in
a game between
a 1700
and in 1800
so pankrative has you know we all have
chess idols and I I guess I'm assuming
he came prepared I'm assuming he's not
ringing this but that is that is
fascinating wow
looks like good preparation thus far to
me after Knight takes D4 we have a queen
trade and this bishop can come to F6
where there's a pin down the diagonal uh
it starts to look like black is doing
okay but at some point this Knight when
Lana B5 in return and go for the fork on
C7 you first developed the bishop to E3
then try to play Knight B5 so pankratov
playing very quickly and the good thing
for abdusidorov is he can draw this game
and then go to game four where puncroft
is a must win situation
yeah that's exactly right
this is uh this is this is this is very
interesting
the way this game has gone uh it is it
is just balanced H5 is a completely okay
according to the computer by the way
stockfish 15 is like yeah
sure you want to play H5 go ahead it
seems like you play anything in this
position
I know is that pancrata must avoid end
games where he's up a pawn
it's got to be equal
you know that's the only way he must be
shocked that he lost that game he was
just out playing his other Pawn it's one
of the positions you can never lose
until you lose it and then you're
yeah you're questioning your entire life
in no sense but here Bishop E3 this is
actually going to turn very bad for
black I think if you play C5 thinking
you're winning an exchange you are not
because the Knight comes to B5 and
there's this Fork on C7 and that's no
fun four block you see the evaluation of
our favorite white and I think it should
be even better than 0.4 it looks very
nice
yeah this looks really really nice and I
just get again the Bishops are super
strong upon on H3 no longer allows
White's King to get out on G2 but it's
potentially just a liability because
black has a defendant for the whole game
from C8 so
uh A4 is also very annoying yeah I like
I like how this looks a lot we could be
seeing norger back punches ticket here
if he just sort of continues this
positional grind
Knight D7
Knight's trying to go to E5 I can get
behind that
not an easy movie to play Retreats are
always difficult but still Knight D7
pretty good choice so why don't we
maybe check on the last game the one we
haven't seen yet between Neil sarin and
Vladimir krummick so we're going to move
on to the former world champions game
against the Indian teenage sensation and
look at Crema go Levy he's playing like
non-committal chess right
I know everything's on the third rank
he's not allowing any of Black's pieces
to
touch anything in White's territory
black has played A5 which prevents B4 if
white got B4 successfully he would be
very happy
this is very cram Nick esque it feels
like maybe we'll see a 91 Knight C2 and
then Rook B1 B4 maybe we'll see another
you know we'll see
a way for white snipe to somehow control
the center squares although there's no
way to get a knight on D5 really but
could also see Bishop D2 Rook C1
and then something like uh along those
lines they have very kramnic-esque
position I mean just
a lot of different plans and
opportunities we might even see some F4
I don't know move the Knight playing for
very fluid position a lot of different
plans
but I I like the fact that there are
many different plans for white but not
for black you can't get D5 to work in
these positions especially when this
Knight moves out the way so what is neon
going for he goes Bishop B6 to my eyes
it's a pretty like ambiguous move but I
think he was trying to avoid D4 with
Tempo against the bishop yep
but
I don't know I mean White's gonna play
Bishop B2 and then he can basically do
anything
he can play all sorts of moves he can
play B4 he can play D4 he can play on
night jump he can play okay there's D4
right so black just moved out of the
center with Knight E7 so he plays D4 I
really like White's position I don't see
a good plan for black if you start
trading here you're not going to get D5
in because white will just press 4 with
C5 and you don't necessarily want to
take on D4 to open up this bishop and
the E file I don't like this one bit for
knee-high so cramped yeah
extremely cramped position
Ed Knight E4 or ed4 to try to play B4
and C5 whichever Chromebook does I like
that better
okay
yeah that's sort of like I I I I think I
once did some video on Magnus and end
games and I and I was like if he if he
makes moves you don't ask questions you
just enjoy yourself
I'm just I think my just watch my
favorite part of this is that he made
the move d4 and I was thinking about his
recapture so and it seems like he
intuited that D4 is the correct move it
makes sense and I moved away for black
and now he's like actually Levy great
question how do I take on D4 and he
takes to the pawn and I was actually a
slightly worse Choice according to the
evaluation bar
yep
but it looks very natural and yeah we
see C6 from nihal nihal is not really in
the
in the business of getting his dark
squared Bishop locked away forever and
ever so he's trying to get it back to C7
I'm really impressed with his ability to
just sort of handle a unpleasant
position and uh
not get his Bishop trapped not get
positionally dominated
he's gonna bring his Bishop back to C7
if he successfully plays D5 he actually
even has a nice position because his
bishops come alive
so yeah the kramnik to figure it out
agreed so D5 played we'll see how
kremnik continues from here I've just
noticed saying that Anish giri is on a
five minutes versus 12 for Roundup so
either that means that Raonic has uh
surprised Anish in some ways
although
um yeah maybe maybe it's just a niche
playing good moves and around it playing
quick moves yeah that that does
definitely I
what it feels like as long as he keeps
himself enough time and doesn't get into
a fatal time trouble
yeah it's gonna be a niche I listen to
Niche so far the most dominant of the
day for sure
yes this game is just completely busted
and white only needs a draw so even if
there's some winning
Choice it'll just make the draw if he
sees it so some kind of Perpetual now
this is just over we don't need to look
at this anymore
um I'm very confident that Niche Curie
is going to win he's all the activity in
the position the safer King the Knight
on e7's pin can really move even if it
weren't because the bishop dominates it
so yeah let's move away from here very
tough position to look at let's go back
to the game between Andre Miss Panko and
dingley ren there's a king on E2 and
white remains up a pawn Levy so
you taking white stuff
uh
depends on the next few moves I think
but I yeah I am
I am I mean if you play Knight H5
there's G3 there's no checkmate Pawn is
a pawn
is a pun
you know what I mean like
good luck proving white needs two more
moves Rook D1 Queen E3 black resigns not
not really but
that's it that's the end of it and then
white is just pushing in an end game so
yeah they'll take white I'll take ding
wing and winning on command no problem
well Andre yesapenko is down two and a
half minutes on the clock he's been he
played very quickly in the opening and
since then he's been the one burning
time Knight H5 played Rook D1 not out of
the question either because Knight F4
came out by King to F1 and you've
castled by hand but G3 as you were just
mentioning that also is viable taking
away the F4 Square I just not sure I
love the look of rook's doubling in the
f file in the event of G3
yeah I
you might have just convinced me that
I'm not as certain as I thought I was
but then there's Rook hf1 I I believe in
dingly run
okay I believe because here's the thing
he doesn't win this game I don't think
he's winning the next one so and I'm not
ready to see no dingley run okay
I mean I'm ready to see yes Pango I'm
not cheering for either guy or something
but I just feels the top level event
feels weird when ding the run's not in
it you know what I mean I agree I think
we should go back if it was just to show
what happened we saw Queen C5 and the
reason the king is on E2 is that this
moment the king went to F1 because if
you play Queen E2 you lose all your
pieces let's check let's check to your
Rook bye bye thank you very much so King
went to F1 and then after black castles
you could take on C3 but that allows
things like Rook C1 and now white
quickly goes after Black's position
Queen D6 after as well could be a
problem with the Rook no longer an A1 so
instead castles and then Queen C1 and
the King drops out to E2 so Knight H3 is
dingly Run's choice he's covering F4
with his Knight so he doesn't make his
pawns get looser I still don't see why
this if I didn't see the evaluation bar
I would just think that white is better
yeah because there's no there's no
danger anywhere here for white
I mean you have to be careful but
there's no danger
you know what I mean so I I agree which
is why I keep and then the essepenco
evidently also I must say is looking
like a like that is not the face of a
man who is super sure he has
compensation for upon he lost he looked
like he's in A Clockwork Orange like his
eyes were forced open
foreign
[Laughter]
I saw that movie for the first time when
I was way too young to see that movie uh
I'm sure it left the last thing damage
so yeah he does he looks he looks
he looks a little uh a little all over
the place a little distraught now he
looks now he looks a little better all
right but let's not consume the finger
completely and dingley Wren has an Eric
icy Vibe where he just
occasionally kind of moves his lip a
little bit and
you know that's when that's when you
know but he always he always kind of has
the same I've never seen a poker face
quite as good as our generic I sees
though
the guy never ever reacts even whenever
it's like how do you feel that you're
gonna play Magnus you're in the final
yeah I feel good it'll be interesting
that's the that's the number one the top
two words chess players use are okay and
interesting no it's like very
interesting game but okay
[Laughter]
it's like it doesn't matter what culture
you're from you just say oh okay but
okay and complicated just to yeah I
really love you it was very interesting
like complicated game oh a niche won
that game so he wins the match three two
zero and oh oh my gosh I'm just gonna
show the final move of this game
gosh poor brownick so roundek was hoping
for Rook takes E7 check Queen takes
seven Rook C7 because as you see you're
winning the black queen but no you're
not because Rook B1 check distracts the
White Queen for the defense of the Rook
on C7 so that's actually a really nice
little tactic so how does Anish deal
with that he says I am going to create
Luft for my king whether H4 have fun
with that pawn over here because if you
take it we get this situation where now
Rook B1 check is met by the very simple
King H2 and black resides
yeah that's brutal
but it was always meant to be
it was always meant to be Anish giri
just showed up today
and
he played one of the most convincing
matches I've ever seen him play honestly
he he said y'all really thought raunich
said wani
I mean was gonna beat me
like router's good but I'm me damn it
three nothing
so he now waits for the winner of
pancreas of norgerberg what's going on
in that match by the way what whatever
happened with all this H5 stuff
oh here we go we bring up the oh my gosh
puncratsov is has a minus three
Advantage right now look at these pieces
on the dark squares
unbelievable looks awful
what
what is this match no but oh wait this
is a worse nightmare for him because
he's gonna be a pawn up in an end game
oh wait no for now that for now is equal
Ah that's good okay never mind
so it's fine Rook D5 played here if
Bishop D5 and in plane said the D5 have
been closed H2 could be captured at some
moment so Rook D5 is a fascinating
choice
can you just start taking these probably
not I was gonna say yeah can you just
snap snap just A4 yeah
I'll be two check as well
oh no for nobody like abducator if he's
in a world of hurt
that's it I really think so he's gonna
lose the B Pawn then he's gonna lose the
H Pawn
and his pawns aren't equipped enough to
create any sort of counter play this is
insane
didn't we like narrative Exposition at
some point
I think this match has completely just
destroyed my understanding of Chess I I
don't understand anything that's going
on between these two one moment one guy
is better then he's dead lost
I don't know
I don't know at all I don't know I
wonder where it all went wrong because
this looks kind of fine not a big deal
Bishop C4 all is
good I made a woman blunder apparently
E4 was a horrible move along this Rook
before tactic with B5 and stuff so E4 is
where
nobody's lost the thread yeah maybe
maybe not your Brick's not playing his
best today I feel like I feel like he's
he's allowed a lot more chances than
normal and having said that pankrative
is playing very very well but then
karate like the only games we've ever
seen him play poorly he just completely
implodes
I think that game four versus Anand
but otherwise he's smooth sailing
it's just like going around the
racetrack and then one time his car
flips over 50 times it's like it's just
I don't know that's just sort of what
happens hopefully it doesn't happen this
game he doesn't have any more room for
error
super strong player and right now he
looks like he's going to win with the
black pieces in this game and even up
this match so a huge moment for
ponkratov and did you see that what not
your back doesn't drink out of glasses
he drinks out of the entire picture
what a Shad like this I have a big water
bottle okay it holds you know it holds
32 ounces of water 900 milliliters but
like that man just drank the whole
picture he just did the boss
oh my god well when you're in Olympia
Champion you do whatever the heck you
want and nobody telling you what to do
so that was that was hilarious wow so
pancato is going to win the H2 pawn and
then ultimately he's gonna have two past
pawns and um
yeah but it's dangerous he is up a pawn
so
I guess there's not be up upon I don't
know somehow like just he's also up six
and a half minutes so I do have faith in
his ability to convert this one uh let's
go back to the Andre Andreas fenko game
I was gonna say on draken every time I
see on Draco as his username I want to
say on draken but is yes a panko with a
black piece against dingley red this is
looking better and better for the world
number two player from China you're just
up a pawn right now
yeah
that's that's the danger of playing prep
where you go down upon is your down upon
I know it sounds crazy but might be
controversial but that's that's what it
is yeah
takes a second Pawn his King has gone
from F1 to E2 and now up to D3 and
probably over to C2 yeah what's what's
the big deal who cares King's going out
what's going on he's having a good time
I'm just gonna go back to C2 at some
point sure
but
I think he'll be safe he'll be all right
we need D7 checks down the D file over
here
looks a little bit worrisome
why
where's the checkmate I don't see
Checkmate but I see pawns hanging
everywhere
I forgot about the pawns I did in fact
forget about the park Queen D5 Queen oh
my goodness
yes
he checks him very important seizing
back control of the game on his Tempo
and then he now he offers a queen trade
this is a completely winning end game
right so
the C Pawn is going to be the deciding
factor here it's completely winning have
to trade Rooks because background
Checkmate and then you're up a pawn and
you see the evaluations through the roof
so we see Queen C7 Queen E6 no access on
the D file for the black queen anymore
he's so good
yep
clean very very clean game here uh thus
far from from ding playing into this
sharp preparation got exactly what he
wanted honestly you almost kind of
Wonder like yes you panko
well the nimsa was a very forcing line
but
you know you could always play a qgd
right if you want with black you don't
always have to play a nym so and ding
played F3 which is just one of the
sharpest lines
that exists I I spent a couple weeks
doing prep on the F3 nimso and then I
decided not to play it because I just
don't understand what's going on at all
and uh in in these positions that we saw
today
clearly one of the two players wasn't
fully kind of grasping he got all his
prep and then got nothing I mean imagine
that right you play all your preparation
and you lose without a peep he he's
tried his best but he hasn't been able
to generate any sort of play
um Robert I feel like this prep is
really good for 90 minute chess
classical because you have time to
figure it out but here you just Pawn
down and it actually reminds me again
even in a classical game U.S
Championship it was linear Dominguez
against Alex Linderman of some deep
preparation but Dominguez was up a pawn
and then Linderman made one inaccuracy
and then the position went from like
slightly better for white to much much
better and here Rook D3 stabilization in
White's position there's just nowhere to
go the C4 Square you would love to play
Queen C4 as black you don't have it 17
seconds and Andre yesapenko I mean
unless he
finds a miracle here he is going to lose
this third game I even wonder if dinkin
played G4
and combine because right now Black's
plan is stability and white can't really
push because the king's a bit weak but
if ding plays G4 now black has no
stability black is desperately trying to
defend the position so you completely
flip the script Black's not searching
for counter play anymore Black's just
holding on you know as the roller
coaster goes up and down but no ding
plays Knight F2 I like G4 but
okay this is also good
by the way Queen A6 is three pawns up
literally a free fun
games
Queen A6 is there a downside to that
move because when you're up two pawns
you don't really need a third extra pawn
and as you're saying Queen C5 hitting
the Knight threatening Queen A3 just
getting into White's Camp over here
looks unnecessary
oh you know what I thought you had I
thought you had Queen C5 Queen D6 Queen
F2 Rook D2 but there's Queen A7
defending the Rook I thought you uh
could win some material here but oh you
also have Queen B6 oh
okay that entire idea just goes to show
that Queen C5 is uh it's a problematic
move you don't want to allow that type
of counter play wow I
I would never play like this and that's
why he's 2800 you know what I mean like
look at him it's and he's playing the
best moves too 93's bringing this piece
up and there's no there are no access
points not B3 not B2 not B1 notches not
this diagonal G4 H4 just G4 it's really
good especially when your opponent of
seven seconds left
because now you stabilize now there's no
counter play Black can't move h4g4 just
do it just gotta go for it
yes
yes there it is that's it three seconds
for Andre okay if you're trading Brooks
in this position you're just
dead lost yep oh my gosh love that move
yep
now you can trade and your Queen's
already more active
Knight D5
one threat one thread you play G4 Andre
just couldn't he didn't know what to do
and queen C7 is that force a queen trade
Queen C7 looks good
hey five H4 whatever C4 pushing his
pawns one second for Andre he might just
lose some time nope he gets the move oh
Queen C6 anybody
that's so unnecessary
okay it's it was probably very
reasonable to 97 Knight F5 everything
looks good Queen D6 yeah Queen D6 is a
nice move
I think we see it's also nice
Queen C6 still nice oh
that'd be too much and
still playing but here comes the C Pawn
a second Queen is going to appear Knight
takes up six and queen D7 Force the
queen trade
Queen F6 Queen A4 be careful that's
actually a funny attack there going for
the knife oh gosh
yeah this is like this is like game one
but the players are reversed
yes game one also had a past pawn and
and it was just it was I believe it was
a c Pawn with a queen trapped away and
that's crazy now it's now it's anybody's
match once again and I mean by anybody
it really it's back to who's the
favorite and the favorite is dingley Ren
I wouldn't say 92 to eight like our
community has it but that's huge I mean
yes ifenko winning with black that first
game was just so massive
just so so massive but now thing Strikes
Back
and yes the panko he's going to need to
take this break regroup because it's no
fun to lose a game especially when you
feel like the match was in your control
but look at this position every time we
tune into this match Levy point two
better for chromic just always or or for
nehal like it was just very very
slightly better and maybe in that first
game for a move or two
but yeah super tense match I'm assuming
Dodger back has lost he lost yes yes
okay wow so we're gonna have a lot of
even matches and then Anish giri who
decided that you know he has an
appointment to get to so he's gonna just
win as fast as possible
um maybe you may be a date night you
know maybe uh
you know he he wanted to spend some more
time with the family so he was like I'm
gonna win all my games in absolutely
destructive fashion and I'm going to I'm
gonna go so he was so impressive I think
you know we compliment him a bunch but
even the comments we gave him don't
really do justice to know what he did no
he destroyed Relic and like I I like I
said ronic didn't even play that bad he
might he might he himself might feel oh
I played bad but I really feel like
nobody was going to beat Indonesia today
he was just Unstoppable
yeah phenomenal showing he Nets himself
minimum 15K right next to one he gets
ten thousand dollars if you lose in the
round of 32 you still are rewarded with
a nice monetary prize so here we see
white has these double pawns on C4 and
C5 black has all of this activity uh to
Bishop pair for white but the bishop
pair doesn't seem that amazing at the
moment and Rook E3 get that Bishop out
of here
yeah once again these Double C pawns I
don't know what it is about the
structure Rook D1 oh my
what a move you have to play Bishop B2
right is there a knight E4 there
are you trying to bring your knight all
the way in I guess
I don't think it works out we can show
this quickly um here 94 takes and I do
this T3 Rook T3 yeah yeah Rook F1 and
then you get you get trapped yeah that's
unfortunate
yeah well
I won't play that
nope yeah he went just
this just goes back
five he's gonna come around from the
other angle
he's gonna try
so it's even material but it almost
feels like Black's up a pawn because
these are doubled and isolated so
Bishop E6 but now Bishop C3 perhaps
yeah every pawn move is so subtle like
who wants the pawn on A5 who wants the
pawn on A4
and once again the house down a bit on
time but that doesn't really mean
anything because it's probably like you
said one of the best bullet players in
the world
oh gosh this uh situation here four
minutes 20 seconds for chronic 125 uh
Chromebooks did very quick today I was
giving him a little bit of flack earlier
making a moral degradation joke but
every single game he's got an advantage
on time and then even when he's down to
20 seconds he's using that increment
well
yeah he is he he he's had some tense
time scrambles but for the most part
he's done a very nice job
of playing extremely accurately too
that's the thing he both of these guys
have played at a very very high accuracy
even in their tensest moments
and we've kind of ended our days
watching them play
that's what it feels like we've ended
the day every single time in the matchup
watching them play Rook F1 yeah it
doesn't work it's a rook d8 check I was
just gonna say that yeah you think
you're gonna get a tactic and then you
got a little too fancy
okay Rook takes I think this is headed
for a draw there is a way to lose with
black which is to get your a pawn taken
like A4 Bishop C3 but yeah Knight D7
will keep the black the dark squared
Bishop occupied and I guess black will
just bring the king
and then at some point black can also
consider trying to create an outside
pass Pawn uh but yeah bringing the king
makes a lot of sense
run that way I still feel like there
there is there might be a way for
the a pawn to fall
and for the C5 Pawn to fall but I don't
see it anyway there's really no way to
do that without allowing some serious
counter play although king cafe might be
a little careless I was about to say if
we just show why king of Fate Bishop E4
now C6 is under attack and if you play
Knight B8 as a way defend it then Bishop
C3 after A4 I can just win your pawn and
then I have the outside pass Pawn not to
mention Bishop E5 to D6 and take C
signaling everything is collapsing here
so
um F5 is a very very nice move taking
away the active Bishop E4
yeah kremnik is going to still continue
to put the pressure but we'll see if
nihal is able to
defend and 30 seconds that's the problem
for Neo right now I think he might lose
this game
I think so 20 seconds and you just have
to defend all of your weak Pawns
no 18 seconds he doesn't know what to do
she's just kidding I guess he's gonna
take if a king E6 very quickly yeah and
try to get Bishop D5 and maybe he's even
but then but then bp7 rg7 is hanging
oh there's no check so the Knight can
come back to D7 I guess
aha
wow
can this actually work yeah six is that
the plan but now taking King E6 G7 is no
longer hanging
that's so subtle brilliant end game
played by these two I'm learning so much
watching this match
these guys are just at a different level
it feels like really it's almost a shame
they have to play each other now
and is there a way if this King were not
on G2 like on this diagonal I feel like
white would have some pretty good
chances but with Bishop D5 check being
the threat and that is a threat it's not
just oh we're trading Bishops to draw
You're Gonna Lose C5 after that and then
black can play uh for a win
yep
Bishop D5 is uh always going to be a
thing
there it is
where is the king going maybe just
Retreat it I guess stay on the light
dark swears excuse me away from this
bishop would make sense but I just don't
see how white ever gets to push the
spawn
yeah now without losing the bishop and
by the time you move the bishop it will
be blockaded
mm-hmm here come the pawns H5 H4 at some
point let's get those going two minutes
still for crumbling I mean he is playing
at a blistering pace and nihal he's the
bullet King so 22 seconds is an eternity
he can
there is a world where nehal sarin makes
an outside h-pawn by the way
and under the right circumstances can
absolutely play this for a win
I don't know I wouldn't be I I wouldn't
be so sure we've seen the end of the
plot twist yeah Knight C4 is also an
issue that white needs to deal with
hitting the bishop and the pawn A3 so if
I'm chromic I might start thinking how
do I just make this game a draw as
quickly as possible
yep
I completely agree with you
125. oh boy
you probably hear
face in hand he's very concentrated but
Bishop B5 there might be Bishop C4
checks is Bishop C7 hitting this
opponent A5
right back well you could always say
goodnight and make the draw right
obstacles Bishops chat doesn't know
that's a draw in like 99 of situations
uh
doesn't really matter and that that is
one of the ways you can always bail out
in an end game is to lose upon but
create a fortress on the opposite color
actually in this case it wouldn't even
be the Ops color it would just be uh in
this case black is even maybe playing
for more on that H file
wow sport
I guess the king gets back in time but
this is a risky Choice from chronic
there yeah that's definitely a risky
choice
I
I hate the way it looks at first but
kramnik played it so I gotta you know
what I'm saying like I gotta challenge
my own Frameworks of chess
G4 he's gonna take on C6 after this ah
he's making a blockade whoa yeah 95 oh
gosh
probably doesn't have that much time if
GF king of King D4 there's H2 yep
but there is there Bishop C2 there
or no because the king walks away from
checks you just hang all your pieces but
the pawn promotes
and that's all you need
all you need is 15 seconds for Krum Nick
oh no takes takes
Bishop C2 where where's the draw
it says zeros but I don't see the draw
Bishop H7 and the bishop G8 is that
possible
G7
oh my goodness chances for both right
now oh and if King F7 Bishop H7 King G7
Bishop E5 check
that's so nice
take check and
wow he does it this way
Oh What A Move G8
what is going on this is unbelievable
take
and queen F3 check oh what a precise
move keep everything protected yep yep
there it is
what a move two seconds come to go
oh this should be for oh God
gonna try to flag him here there's just
no way that he accepts the draw
no commit Queen B2 just keep your pieces
defending just runs with his king queen
of five check will win a piece be
careful he was Bishop F4
oh gosh no time
oh a blunder Queen G6 check
could you say queen of five quit a five
five oh no
poor Vladimir
oh my goodness Vlad is gonna
oh and Vlad loses
that was literally the worst case
scenario that was the only way
that it felt like it was possible to be
Vladimir kramnik literally that was the
only way his Precision in the end game
was legitimately unbelievable
I feel like 90 of that field would have
lost that end game 15 moves prior I mean
it was just he was so surgically precise
and it's it's the time that gets him but
this move is also he had a minute and
three seconds he could take on C6 make a
draw right he had that option he went F4
and after H4 now you have this problem
with the outside pass Pawn so he kind of
did this to himself at this moment and
then Knight E5 and then at this point
they're playing accurate moves look at
the evaluation bar zero zero still Zero
by the way oops sorry click the end but
that move there Queen F6 check what a
move King takes here Queen takes and you
get this bishop that was really nice but
Levy you just got to give it to nihal
son he ran with his King and then he
said I'm going to plan your time trouble
and this could happen over the board it
could happen with five seconds increment
10 seconds agreement just mistakes
happen when your King's out in the open
yeah just
this this was how nihal sarin was was
going to be Vladimir kramnik today was
going to be keeping Pace with him
matching him kind of punch for punch
resource for resource and if it ever got
to a Time scramble the odds went from
around 55 45 to like 90 10. that was
just the truth that was the harsh
reality of the situation when you get an
event like this where it's Mouse speed
and uh
it's kind of like the reaction time and
everything and then keeping those nerves
it's a totally different world in this
online realm and that is where nihala's
is the overwhelming favorite it's it's
bittersweet because at the end of the
day it's part of the format we want to
have great chess but we also want to
have some of the best players in the
world not have to fly anywhere and be
able to play from the comfort of their
own home for high stakes and high prizes
so full credits in the hall because he's
he's gone toe-to-toe with Vladimir
kramnik over three games and going into
the fourth game he has a 2-1 lead we've
had some players waiting for a while so
we're going to take a very short break
when we come back we're gonna have a
fourth rapid game here in the round of
32 of the chess.com Global championship
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
to anyone
all around the world are you kidding me
the chess.com Global Championship offers
the dream of playing against the best
whoa and hey have we mentioned there's
also a million dollars at stake the
total pot is a million dollars no that
it's not a typo the prizes are
unbelievably generous we began with
thousands of players now only dozens
remain you don't just do this to
shockery are in a critical game except
Alexis Verona just did gorgeous chess he
makes his way into the round of 16.
The cgc Knockout phase has arrived
there are those who played their way in
and some are here thanks to their
well-earned reputations
[Music]
no matter who you are things are about
to get very very real
Duda move on to the round of 16
trip to the cgc finals and clean shot at
the largest first place prize of the
year
my friends it's the cgc round of 32. who
will take the next step to Toronto
and return here to the round of 32 of
the chess.com Global Championship we
have three matches remaining of today's
action because Anish giri swept roundek
said wani and Andrea sapenko he jumped
out to a one-point lead winning game one
with black against England and then
unfortunately for him after a draw in
game two he suffered defeat in game
three we see him walking around his room
trying to gather himself make sure that
his emotions are in check but Levy what
a devastating third game for the Russian
20 year old uh devastating third game
yeah but sick room that he's in uh and
also he won with black in game one so he
lost but he also knows he's more than
capable of beating dim he's got the
confidence and right now when you when
you even out a match like that right
like you go down after you win uh game
number one you're not thinking oh man
this guy is just
oh he's God he's just so he's not
feeling what round looks like why he's
feeling he's feeling all right I want a
game now he won a game match on I get
white uh and last time it was an
interesting game let's see what happens
this time so he sits back down nice and
focused and I'm also nice and focused
now that I got my my what is he eating I
was gonna say I got my coffee what what
was that yeah
I'm gonna ask him he's got his he's got
his Lacoste hoodie he's got the beef
jerky that looked like beef jerky I
don't know I don't know what it was he
looks like he's ready to participate in
ludovic's chest boxing event
yeah I would not like to fight him uh I
think he's a is he big you saw him in in
vike right is he a big guy yeah he's
tall he's very tall I mean he's uh
he's also a really strong chess player
so if you're not gonna knock him out
physically well good luck to all of us
on the board and they are playing that
variation that we saw in game two but
here instead of Queen C2 he did take on
D5 playing into the main variation black
has only one part of the center white
has two over here that's good news for
yesterday panko but as is typical ding
Loren strikes with C5
yeah and this time we don't see any
Queen c2s we see the principled kind of
play but Queen C2 does happen it's
definitely a move it helps white support
the center and then it also clears out
that back rank newbies know we gotta get
the Rooks connected they gotta have the
they got to be able to see each other uh
and that that helps a lot for the
long-term development of your position
this is a very exciting matchup the
truth is though that uh
the truth is that
um it's these kind of positions often
Peter out like in the first like 15 20
moves I mean it's it's just
it's Queen's Indian is is a is an
opening where there can be Mass trades
very early uh which we are already
seeing but in this case there there are
ways for white to get very aggressive I
was about to say H4 but now we have
Castle
and after you Castle you still play H4 I
would say the issue that I'm seeing here
for yessa panko is that the position for
black is relatively easy to play for the
time being and with it being closed and
not a position with tactics
even though yes the panko is an amazing
player that just has to favor dingley
red we saw him win that last round of
candidates against Hikaru Nakamura in a
position that looked like there was
nothing and he squeezes and squeezes
until finally his opponent breaks so
this position I like it for dingler and
even though we're in standard opening
territory
that was extremely professional chess
commentary and allow me to just
interject with something completely and
wholeheartedly unprofessional so I see
Chad is discussing that yesipenko was
eating a fig I hadn't actually seen what
he ate I just saw him holding something
and take a strong bite out of it so no I
I my American is not kicking in I didn't
think a fruit was uh was beef jerky but
did you know uh that I was once having
dinner like the last time I hung I was
with my uncle and we were actually in
Mongolia you wouldn't know this I don't
know why I asked did you know I was
offered bear meat like I was offered
like instead of salami they eat like
bear meat and I was like Wow and I I I I
had some and it just it just tasted like
regular salami but uh you're saying yeah
you knew that I didn't know that well I
didn't know it in Mongolia but when I
was in the khantiman Sisk in 2009 uh I
remember that they had like these bear
meat dumplings or something and tasty
uh I didn't eat them but other people
seem to like them
well uh uh I remember
we only have like one more move uh
played and we will we will cover the
game we promised when I went to coach
the world Cadet us team uh the junior
players in in Wei Fung China
obviously there is there is a can be uh
a cultural Clash there but really it was
the kids right like the the young kids
were they didn't know how to eat food
that they hadn't eaten they were like
six they were complaining so what ended
up happening was we were served like
seven types of chicken every day popcorn
chicken fried chicken like chicken
breast chicken thigh chicken nuggets and
by the like the sixth day of eating
chicken and pasta I was like all right I
gotta go to a local restaurant here in
China I gotta get some Chinese food like
you know some I don't know I don't want
chicken all day so I mean and that's one
of the benefits of being able to play
from the comfort of your home you get to
eat what you want you know you can sleep
where you want and that's why the
chestnut Global Championship is great
yeah and I mean both players are very
focused right now look at dingly red
that is determination
epitomize just look at that guy's
concentration right now and he stumbled
in game one against men in the first
match he stumbled in game one against
Andre yesapenko and he stumbled in game
one in the candidates both this last one
and the previous one so I think round
one is just bad for dingley run if he
just never had to play round one maybe
take a a Buy in that round he would be
even higher rated than his 28-10 rating
yeah seriously
he he is so good he's one of the rare
guys that uh that is dingler and that
like can bounce back just incredibly
convincingly and consistently sometimes
he has serious stumbles but he he rarely
goes up down he goes like if anything
down and only up from there and uh he
did it in in the candidates and he's
doing it in this match and I mean it
really felt like he was doing it against
Juan minlay although it wasn't like such
a convincing first defeat but
he can't really count ding the rent out
ever
no you cannot and
look at his position if we start digging
in
a little here so we see that the Knight
A5 was played we have a C file that will
likely open up at some point and this
bishop on B2 it's sort of waiting in the
wings I would love to see a trade that
opens the C file for black but it opens
the diagonal for White Once the move D5
happens and then the black king will be
in danger so it's one of these positions
where the tension will remain and
at some point you may have to pull the
trigger or play C4 and keep everything
closed but once you play C4 now white
never has to be worried about the center
then it's permanently safe
that Bishop on B2 does look a bit
ridiculous but it's actually the best
spot for it because like you just said
if C4 and the bishop was on F4 white
loses the A3 pawn and then white loses
the game because black will play Knight
back to C6
A5 A4 A3 A2 A1
and maybe you won't go that far maybe
you'll just stop it at A3 and it'll be
tough for black to move it'll be tough
for white to move but
um yeah at some point I can't help but
feel like the best plan for white is
still to play H4
okay I'm I'm retiring from commentary
that was perfect thank you thank you you
really should not say another word you
said H4 as he was about to play it so
that was well time and now H5 so he
wants some kind of attack think about
this if you can line your queen and
Bishop up for a battery there's no G6
anymore because the pawn is on H5 that
said you might regret having your Pawn
on H5 if this queen comes on over here
you might lose it or in end games it's a
pawn that is gone potentially too far
but Levy other games are starting here
uh the fourth and final game between
Abdul satara and pankratov is underway
so let's go to that game as well it's
kind of a similar dynamic in a way
yeah very much so wow
I guess the the difference being some of
the pawn structure on the queen side has
cleared out but yeah even here the game
plan very well for white could be could
be some H4 at some point
and noise has to win on demand uh no no
sorry sorry no he doesn't I just for
that I forgot he won that second game it
just really feels like this has been
when krato's match from start to finish
yeah Progressive has played the better
chess right in game two he was up a pawn
and then suddenly he lost that pawn and
then lost the game so uh I believe has
played the better chess of the two thus
far but in game four here
Levy it's like he's down on time Notre
back has almost as much time as he
started with there's already pressure on
the center on the D4 Pawn I'm not sure
if punk rock is very happy right now
no he's not this is kind of like a best
case scenario for for black trying to
play a position for a win you have just
enough imbalances without the risk
but admittedly we are still very early
in the opening
and
I
I I feel like they're okay wow Bishop C6
it's a very deliberate
attempt
at trading off pieces so Bishop
okay wow
we going to a playoff here is that
what's going on these guys are going to
swap their pawns and that'll be that
it looks like it because A2 can be
captured B4 next white should be
slightly better decide for choice you
have all of your Pawns in files next to
one another C6 is isolated so I would
take white well after the series of
Trades even though the position with
best play should be one that is held I
think that the pawn structure speaks for
itself
okay
that will
that will live on I think longer than I
literally don't care but I I but but to
be honest I I feel like once they like
once they're fully integrated as a as
part of you know our chest meme culture
it's only good we just keep absorbing
more and more memes and more and more
dreams and I don't know I wouldn't want
to play a playoff against noisier back
he did win a playoff he did he did win a
playoff that's right he beat nepo in a
playoff for World rapid Champion right
so man's got nerves of Steel but it does
feel like but it it's been pancrative
who has been pushing the pace can we
check it on kramnik
sure if we must Vladimir kremac oh gotta
make me
go to vacuum now of course the former
world champion has the black pieces in a
must-win game and where is Eric Rosen
I'm sure he's watching somewhere oh yeah
she's probably sleeping
this is a London system
yeah
it's London which uh is something that
I've seen nehal Trot this out very
interesting to see how kramnik handles
the London and he handles it in a
hedgehogy way
mm-hmm very peaceful start here and
white just has more space thanks to
having two pawns on the fourth rank none
of Black's pieces passed his own third
I remember when I was first learning the
London back before it was cool you know
uh as people like to say about various
songs and things and so on I I hated
when people played like this because I
never understood what I was supposed to
do I'm not so like when am I supposed to
play H3 Bishop H2 when am I supposed to
play A4 when do I play Knight C4 I would
study the games of gotta komsky and then
I would just not
understand how to implement that you
ever have that it's really annoying you
just don't know what to do you're like
all right well they do it but how do I
do it so that's why I don't recommend
the London for uh the newest of players
it gives you a sort of confidence in
that you can play eight moves of Chess
and then after that you're like wait I
don't know what to do from here because
there's no tension look at this position
if we just look across the board here uh
there is no pawns challenging one
another the position is not open so you
actually have to come up with deep
strategical reasoning which is not
always easy for newer players to the
game and how does white respond to
Knight to D5 I I I don't know Queen B3
looks pretty normal I guess that's
that's why I I don't know it's so much
easier to watch than to play
that's that's the uh that that's the
tricky thing is it too late to play H4
here
[Laughter]
then I don't have a knight's on f8 so
there's no nothing is going to H7
I really don't have a good handle on
these positions I was just playing with
like Queen D2 or I guess a queen B3
before but I always feel like both sides
are fine and then I kind of get aimless
yeah it's very easy to do that because
black is Rock Solid
black is Rock Solid here any move by
white can create a potential weakness
in in their own position like C4 creates
a weakness yeah D4 B4 exactly
I think Rook B8 is a possum but then you
might walk into C4 C5 so you always to
be careful about this London Bishop
hanging out it's a long range piece so
Rook V8 could be a mistake so mihal is
just hanging out he's chilling let's go
to
are other matchups because I believe the
game between ding Lee Wren and Andre
yesapanko has changed quite a bit and
look at this black is down a pawn if I
can count pawns correctly but
no problems according to the Evo bar
just I know how is that possible
where did that pawn go H4 H6
wasn't dingly red
six
take it
and then he goes Bishop F6
and apparently it's slightly better for
white but can we just instant replay
that Asics
why
what am I missing something
I think dingley red is just a brilliant
chess player and he sees
the prospects of the position whereas
that pawn was irrelevant and what I want
to do is open up the position trade
Queens plant a knight on C4 which
attacks B2 attacks A3 and protects B6
all at once and his Pawn on H5 we
mentioned that could be a Target The
Rook coming to eight
I don't think this is that bad for black
I don't think it's bad at all
nope
counter play on the a pawn
and we might have a very similar
kind of series of exchanges and we might
see the exact same thing in the
norgerberg pancrat of
match up can we just quickly check what
happened there I doubt we have an H Pawn
there
on on H5
yeah
there we go see no yeah we don't have
um what is the deal here still better
Pawn structure for white
some pressure for black over here watch
out for Rook B8 at some moment your king
could be in some Danger
on the back rank as well
but still looks very very level
yeah it's not not a whole lot here this
will probably be a draw but knowing that
matchup some guy is going to be
completely winning he'll throw to the
other guy and then
four more times the same process will
repeat itself
we've seen all sorts of stuff there
maybe just a a nervous final round here
or game four because all three games
are just calm not particularly exciting
uh Rook A3 we might just see a draw in
this one with the repetition Rook a two
Rook A3 and by the way yessa panko has
pushed his Pawn in the center so I'm
gonna go back there because the big
decision well actually
maybe she would stay here because uh
Queen C3 he changed his mind no draw or
will he make a draw
yeah I don't know it's kind of a sense
of humor Queen C3 but he'll go back to
B2 to repeat
simply Rook B3 wow
K2 does it keep happening is this where
we are
I mean I I see I see you're hovering on
on a list of games we might as well just
watch some three-minute Blitz on
chess.com or something you'll get a
little exciting game yeah these this
last round it seems like
evenly matched players play even games
but not the most exciting compared to
earlier games of today so let's go to
the under on draken it's username is
andreika so Andre yesapanko has that
username so I always want to say on
draken but anyway we have seen the move
D5 plate
Trader pieces trade to Pieces Knight C4
and Rook 2 B4 so I imagine that at some
point black is just going to
win the pawn back
it takes on A3 here Levy
white might stay upon ahead
I don't understand this game but just
the most recreational loss of a pawn I
I've like ever seen but he probably just
understands something we don't the other
thing is it's all on the same side right
so four three three two two one one ZIP
it's all drawn Rook end games
but it's so ridiculous to me that chess
has evolved to the extent that you can
voluntarily lose upon and be like it's a
draw you can't win
I mean it's it's crazy like imagine in
sports ah you can have one more player
than us we know it's a draw there's
nothing quite like that like the fact
that chess is scientific uh study to the
point that you can just be pawned down
and still drawing is
that's kind of it's kind of absurd King
fader okay just middle of the game walk
the king and very high level game this
is just this is a very high level and it
all started with with that move A6 where
dingler engine is just voluntarily
jettison's upon and then he's like nah
all right we're hanging I'm I'm fine yep
doesn't matter G4 if if you were like
giving a private lesson to some kid that
was rated like 1500 be like what are you
doing look I forgot like I just forgot
the pawn was hanging but that was a
deliberate Bond sacrifice to clarify
that matters it's uh do as we say not as
dingley Ren does kind of moment where he
can get away with it yeah yep yeah
that's very much a thing in chess
absolutely
you gotta you gotta you gotta learn the
rules to break the rules
all right what else any anything else
around kramnik that game interesting
am I allowed to say no and we haven't
seen much change here
it's the game with the most what-ifs
let's put it this way and the most stuff
unclarified right so
let's put the good thing is their time
is ticking because we give them each
minute here stuff is gonna happen or it
won't or it won't
look at the last move by the way Knight
E to D2 he wants to go Knight C4 and
create some pressure on these pawns is
this standard way to try to make your
opponent uncomfortable and now Knight F4
seems reasonable opening up your
electric Knight C4 Knight A5 that's kind
of nice
you hit this A6 could be a Target at
some point
so there are some ideas here at the F4
square is blacks the C4 square is whites
some pressure against those Queen side
pawns chronic trying to figure out what
to do so
it's not that simple even if there's
only been one Pawn traded and not much
is happening trying to figure out an
actual strategy is not easy a knight F4
plate and somehow that's inaccurate
I also just remembered kramnik has to
win yes I forgot about that
that is
a bit unfortunate
I have to say
that is a bit unfortunate
so what happens when you get in time
trouble and lose down the stretch of a
very wild game three
yep there's A5
and B5 is you can just play C4 and so
your Bishop is loose over here
yeah it looks like nihal is just putting
the putting the pressure on the bishop
on F1 is such a good defensive piece and
a great offensive piece
what do you do here with black that's
why Bishop's rule
they just
can handle both sides of the board at
the same time as C4 now just
the big problem yeah this is so tough
this is so tough
and G3 almost traps this Knight it can't
go to H5 but the knights on the rim are
looking a bit silly and you're just
winning a pawn now neon that's the
that's the same by the way right nice on
the rim look a bit silly
is it is
rim or dim or grim
official dim
it's dim yeah because you know Grim can
mean like threatening whereas usually
it's dim because it's
what would you use bozo
yeah well what do you mean me you're
from New York too it's like part of our
vernacular where you gotta you never
call someone a bozo of course I call
somebody at bozo but you seem to you
know call everybody a bozo it's like
your way of being friends myself at bozo
too you gotta start with yourself and
yeah
um
yeah okay dim you know I learned the
other day that Yasser sarawan was the
one that invented uh the saying pigs on
the seventh hahaha
I had never heard it until Yasser said
it but Yasser also has told me so many
stories that I don't know where they
come from
yeah besides tillberg and
1982 or something I think Yasser has
lived like one of the most fulfilling
live uh lives in all of Chess honestly I
feel like he's just got so many stories
he's such a such a such a cool guy and
uh he had like that epic hairdo with the
photo back in the day
anyway we're gonna talk about Yasser
because this game has been a bit rough
round's been a little bit rough uh they
drew by the way no it's your back right
nobody back in Punk drew that music
going to Armageddon will let everybody
know of their bids we want to remind
everybody that if it's tied two to two
we go to Armageddon where the players
they bid their time let's say I bid nine
minutes and Levy Bits 10 he actually
gets 15 minutes and the white pieces I
would get nine minutes with black and I
would have to just draw the game uh
which is easier said than done in
Armageddon so okay this is a big problem
for kremnik I will say Levy that even
though white is much better you made
this comment earlier sometimes you have
to play Losing variation or losing
sequence something that gets you in
trouble in order to have winning chances
yeah exactly because your opponent then
has to play sharp chess and accurate
chest to beat you they can't play Lazy
chess which we I don't I'm not saying
it's an insult on the players but for
example this last round
game between not your back and um it was
a relatively like you know effortless it
was a little bit lazy game they just
like kind of played moves and then they
traded pieces like when you're when
you're playing with a big Advantage you
can't play like that because the game
requires accuracy and it requires
critical moments but
right now the problem is that nihal
doesn't even have really that sharp of a
position he has a position where he can
very slowly Advance uh
but beating somebody with black at the
elite level is is so hard
it's just so hard
I
don't ever Envy somebody who needs to
win on demand no matter the color at
this high level but the black piece is
nah it's not not going to happen for the
most part but Bishop D5 the queen will
just move out the way you have a
protected past Pawn there's a rook
behind your pass Pawn over here this
looks so bad for black and yet if nehal
gets in the time travel that we've seen
him get in this position is much more
complicated than those end games so
there is
opportunity for krumnik in this one even
if he is much worse objectively for the
time being
yes if he makes a comeback in this game
it will be it will be spectacular uh it
really will be by the way I was just
going to mention that pankrative it's
his second time playing Armageddon last
time
last time he wagered I don't remember
what but something reasonable and his
opponent Vichy Anand
waitressed seven minutes
to get rods in Armageddon which was
surreal and it was closed for a while
but then pankradev went on a giant
attack and went on to win the game and
if that happens today
I don't know I feel like not your back
is of course the favorite when given two
results
yeah he's also much faster than Vichy is
so much more accustomed to playing
online and Bishop it's seven minutes I
believe Punk cross had been 14 minutes
30 seconds he really wanted to have
white in that match
uh well we should hop on over to our
other game it is closer to the Finish
Line Andrea sapenko down under two
minutes he is still up a pawn and he's
trying to play for a win here you see
the evaluation bar plus one makes sense
when somebody's gone ahead but dingly
right is trying to chase down this Pawn
in various ways
well he's the one who gave it up you
know under no duress whatsoever uh so it
kind of makes sense it was a it was a
very very strange uh moment I must say
but okay it is what it is right like
obviously you you would just we've been
saying he probably just kind of
understands something about the position
we we don't quite I think what's really
going to be the the Difference Maker
here is the one minute that's
look everyone's human
and the good thing is that for yesterday
panko if he screws up the worst thing he
gets is a draw
right which is which is good
a fortunate place to be the Knight comes
back to B5 here goes the pawn to D7 no
Rook C7 the Knight is loose King E7 can
always meant by rookie fourcheck
that's a scary Pawn
yeah I don't know what the computer
doesn't like it's like trying to
complain
he's five
wow
some kind of
whoa Knight seat oh is there like some
night night or something to D5
because Rook D3 Knight D5 Rook D4 can
you get away with this that I was gonna
say I was gonna say maybe just Knight F6
Knight F6 and you attack the g-pawn and
then Rook C7 or something or King E7
oh wow it's that simple sometimes just
bring your knight all the way back and
try to go for the pawn though
not clear that you're gonna get there
because white will bring the Firepower
to the D file as Knight would like to
join an E5 at some point and Rook C1
played by yesterday he's 33 seconds he
has now pinned this Knight here takes D7
is that possible
oh wow
oh wow looks scary right because there's
a check the King has to come up there's
another check they can't go this way ugh
worrisome
I don't need to play here
ding looks like the final boss
thing is a boss
and he'll be playing for a world
championship but right now he's playing
for his Global championship of life
because he is down a past Pawn and I'm
with you Levy I am not sure what ding
should do here but he does have four
minutes to figure it out
if the time situation was reversed this
would be a very very very dangerous
position for black but
given four minutes versus 20 seconds
okay that's that's it yeah that is a
complete draw now
yep look C4 Knight D7 or that
here Rook D4 definitely don't play King
E7 yeah it doesn't come recommended
King E8 that's very very close wow
tricky tricky now you just gotta take
now and
all right we're gonna have at least two
armageddons
you have to see if if kramnik uh
can win after Rook D4 I think Knight 65
also draws but this is a draw offer draw
agreed we have Armageddon here
dingly Wren Escapes in this match loses
game one then takes game three and yessa
panko had an advantage here in game four
so we'll go to the game between nihal
sarin and Vladimir kramnik kremnik is
ahead by a minute and a half almost he
has these aggressive pieces Levy I I
could see the eval bar white is up a
pawn it's looking good but I also feel
like there is some hope for Vladimir
sorry is his last move rookie eight oh
my God you can't even take it huh no the
Fisher it was a bishop that was here I
went to G5 oh oh oh for some reason on
my screen I thought
oh that was so strange I I I guess I
guess it's just waking up am syndrome I
I for some reason I thought the last
highlighted move was E7 to E8 I didn't
realize it was E7 to G5 okay I mean the
728 also would have made sense the queen
guards the the bishop and the The Rook
cannot be taken that's why I was like oh
okay that makes sense
um that would have been a very odd move
but right now Knight takes G2 is a
pretty big threat mm-hmm
yes that's a great piece love that
Bishop yes the bishop has a very
important role that's preventing an
avalanche wow
ignores G2 because B6
and just assured by Knight G2 you're not
taking back on G2 because then Knight H4
check happens and look at this
evaluation black is suddenly
decide for choice
yeah this is a crazy crazy thing that
nehal is doing he just he just does not
care about the attack he's just taking
the Rook
this game could end in about seven moves
because pram Nick might just go all
right I got nothing I like I don't want
to play Rook B7 I just want to go all
out we saw kramnik do that in the famous
candidates where every interview that he
gave was just uh was like noteworthy and
then fun and you know he was like sort
of the tournament strong and then he you
know obviously like had a setback and he
still tried to play for a win every game
it was like epic he might just do that
now but because like otherwise you just
lose your Rook
or you put it on B7 you lose your Bishop
yeah you're not playing Rook B7 here
okay but if you don't play rugby seven
You're Gonna Lose Your Rook so we I'm
saying something Something's Gonna Give
in the next
five to seven moves are in just
cold-blooded men just beating a former
World Champ beating arguably a top 10
player of all time I don't know I was
gonna say arguably top five then I
changed with mid-sentence
I think the case scrambling is a top
five all-time player
of course you can make that argument he
beat Kasparov in the match he's the
world champion
um
yeah I think he's
I have never done this it's not that
fascinating for me uh but I would say
Carlson Kasparov
I mean Fisher was so dominant but he
didn't have the tools that they have
today Vichy
yeah then the fifth spot is hard for me
to you're not one of those guys that
like wants to throw in a guy from like
the early 20th century because he was
I love Kappa Blanca's chess I was gonna
say a couple Blanca yeah yeah big
Captain Blanca fan
but
I'm just looking here
your channel Greco
the man who knew how to play chess when
nobody knew how to play chess
uh you know I'm
yeah I could it could go either way with
Greco it's fine
oh there it is oh
I feel like this is the type of move
that you know doesn't work so you should
play it instantly rather than spending a
couple minutes on it yeah I mean it
was always going to be tough he had to
win with black against foreign
against the
was very very solid setup that nihal has
chosen I wouldn't say that today was any
sort of moral degradation I mean that
game obviously was a draw but there was
still it was sharp pieces were still
scattered
and you know it's not like he flagged
him down like a rook a knight three
pawns or something like that was part of
the game unfortunately and if kramik had
just just in time been able to stabilize
in the last game it would have been all
right but uh nihal sarin is punching his
ticket was he the favorite today in the
matchup
I think so what was our community
prediction I don't we don't have to put
it on the screen but I but I am just
curious if we can see it
behind the scenes
yeah toss-up 54 for chromic but I would
have said that I'm pretty sure I picked
nihal to win this matchup in my bracket
uh he's just so fast he executes his
game plans quickly under the duress of
time trouble yep so I I think nihal is
just an absolute force and he's put a
great match what you were saying is so
true it's not that he flagged or dirty
flagged crumb making game three that's a
type of position that you play on over
the board and I think that's where this
concept from chronic came into play of
moral degradation like oh you're just
flagging somebody Rook versus Rook you
would never do that over the board with
increment you just offer a draw but that
position was very complicated nihal you
know played for a win
yeah exactly you would still try to play
that position for maybe five or ten more
moves as the kings are in the process of
getting made and like if that that was
an over the board Blitz game the same
thing would happen
guys would have kept playing right it's
just it's the same thing it's just that
over the board nobody like okay not
nobody but very very few people's flag
it's very different to play to be
playing online
um
I think nihal has to make a few more
moves and he is going to be our second
uh guy through today
I love how Anish gear has just been like
relaxing on a couch somewhere for an
hour and a half probably watching us hi
Anish
let's see is he watching the show or did
he go like for some some lunch
yeah I mean Anish he's very happy he did
shoot me a message he was proud of his
play today and he should be uh but I was
gonna say back to the
top five players a karpov definitely
deserves a
at least an honorable mention if not
a spot in the top five I didn't mean to
put you on the spot and then you know
make you have to uh
discuss and deliberate and be like damn
I missed somebody no it's it's a
ridiculous list I know I know you're a
basketball fan I'm sure you you don't
enjoy doing the same thing and uh
I mean LeBron is the best player of all
time and then you know we're gonna get
the MJ fans in the chat riled up but
LeBron is uh the goat
that is that is a controversial take wow
for brave speaking up on that one wow
you know me the most controversial
person out there always trying to
stir up drama and
D5 what is happening here 57 seconds for
Neil
nehal has a streamer mentality and what
I mean by that is not that he doesn't
shower or that he doesn't you know clean
up the garbage and it Stacks in a pile
that's not what I'm saying here's the
streamer mentality isn't he's gotta get
like
dangerously low on time to entertain the
audience you know what I mean like how
could have played these moves faster but
he gets it he gets entertainment all
right so he's gonna string us along for
the ride he knows that the longer the
show goes the more ads we can throw in
the hell gets it okay so that's why he's
gonna get us down to 30 seconds again
and then give us all hope
and uh I mean it'll it'll either pay off
or fail spectacularly so he gets it
and chronic with a minute 35 seconds
remaining here he's trying to get some
sort of attack in front of the white
king but D5 was such a nice move just
shutting down the bishop on Aid and also
threatening an attack against the black
king here he's up a piece he's winning
this game he's winning this match
he is
he is he is yeah Kramden kind of has
that the sly smile of I kind of feel
like it's over I mean my pieces are sort
of blocked out I'm down material
uh
it's tough it's tough there's not a
whole lot of moves left either that's
the thing yeah Queen A5
it does attack The Rook
but something tells me the house is
going to see it I don't know what tells
me but that's something something tells
me
little little threat down there on E1
it's a good question where do you move
yeah what's up what's funny I open chat
just to see their reaction at UW I never
look at chat someone someone makes the
worst take of all time there's an easier
argument that LeBron isn't top 10 there
is for him being the goat there is no
Universe where LeBron James is not in
the top get out of here whoever that can
a mod just ban that person that is the
worst take I think I've ever seen so
oh gosh anyway back to the chest Rook D1
staying out of trouble is this Rook
there's still threats against this black
king over here
yes the white King's looking pretty safe
there's rookie it's hanging yes I uh
there's Queen A4 oh that's it that's it
good night
oh good night that is a clean piece up
but he will win the pawn
we'll see I'm trying to find a way to
like save it but
Rook C1 oh
that's nasty threatened back ring
Checkmate and then put the Rook on C7
but there is H6
oh my God he sacked the Knight look what
he's doing
oh my God he sacked the Knight
and he
it's all accurate
that's insane he just gave him a full
piece for no reason to keep his Pawn
I mean obviously there is a reason he's
gonna play Bishop C5 and then like get
the Rook out of the corner it's so red
he's too good
he's
unbelievable
sorry I'm shock Robert I mean come on
are you kidding me
all he needs is a draw
just absurdy gave him a full Beast to
just lock away that rook and that's it
he's completely winning oh my gosh
what a game
this is great stuff for nihal sarin
chronic's face you know he's he's ready
to throw in the towel he's ready to see
his time at the chess.com Global
Championship come to an end and nihal
sarin I mean he won two games in the
speeches championship last year and now
look he's just making a draw that's all
he needs oh Mike is he actually oh my
God he's making a draw
this crime not gonna make him win
that's respectful wow
and nihal sarin look at him celebrating
arms in the air I mean he just looks
beyond ecstatic
he just looks
this is the happiest I've ever seen him
I I love who he literally hasn't even
smiled this dude just took down a
multiple time world champion one of the
most influential chess players of the
past 30 years
and he just looks like he finished an
exam in school
it doesn't even look like he's phased
it's on it's amazing congratulations to
him and he's made it to the round of 16.
I think he's Computing he's like did I
really just win that match he looks
almost
shocked that he's not playing more chess
today or he's tight he's typing he's
typing trying to find a bullet opponent
that's what he's doing he's like let's
go but either way in group G he has made
it through now will he face dingley red
or Andre yesapanko that remains to be
seen But congratulations are in order
for nihal sarin and Anish giri who have
made their way through to the round of
16. yes we have been informed that not
here back Abdul sotura has wagered 10
minutes
has wagered 11.55 so this time a bit
more of a adventurous wager from him not
14 minutes not necessarily trying to
secure that that spot with the white
pieces we don't yet have the numbers for
dingly Ren and Andrea cipenko but when
we return we will finish up our morning
coverage here in the round of 32 with
our two remaining Armageddon games don't
go anywhere we'll see you in just a few
minutes
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
ER to making a good first impression
Andre yesapenko had his hello world
moment at the turn of last year
competing at the prestigious Tata steel
tournament jessupenco managed a shocking
victory over the reigning world champion
Magnus Carlson it is just groundbreaking
one of the only players who have a
winning record against Magnus Carlson
only 18 at the time yesterday panko made
history as the youngest player to hand
Carlson a defeat in a classical game
during his world championship reign
Andre yes
late summer the teen sensation had saved
plenty of Mojo for competing in one of
the final opportunities to qualify for
the cgc
oh man he's got quite the mouse
showing the gears on his bike there
dominating his play in session yesapenko
won six of his nine games including
three draws to take first place and
punch his ticket to the round of 64.
despite his age and lack of experience
compared to other veterans in his group
yassipenko has every reason to believe
he can earn a seat at the table in
Toronto this November asapinco that
young man is very well known and very
dangerous and fast time controls and the
community spoke 80 percent of people
think he's gonna move on
foreign
here Andre yesapenko on screen or well
maybe off screen now he's taking a walk
he is getting himself set for Armageddon
Levy he's a beast but he is taking on
dingley red
he is taking on dingly Wren and he's
giving himself a little maybe pep talk
psyching himself up we oftentimes
oftentimes see fighters in the locker
rooms before a fight you know walking
back and forth screaming like you know I
even got this and whatnot you know
you're the man nobody can beat you this
kind of a thing I don't know if they
quite do that in chess as we see the
head-to-head here uh obviously the
chestnut come rapid rating slightly
different
not there goes to dingly Wren but yes
sir panko has qualified his way here you
know what I mean and he knows what it's
like to take down top dogs like when he
took down Magnus Carlson uh and they are
going to play an Armageddon where he
will have the white pieces he bid 13. so
dingley Ren bid I believe 1024 was the
exact number which is a very unique
number leave it to dingler and not to
have a five or a zero at the end I think
that's the most uh interesting kind of
one that we've had so far so uh
an interesting and interesting spot here
so it's going to be a four and a half
minute time advantage
for Andre which uh
that's substantial I have to say I mean
that's that's that's big and uh this is
the one game for all the marbles
basically to make it to the round of 16.
can't forget when dingley Ren took ikaru
Nakamura down to the wire in the speed
chess championship last year so he can
play without much time on his clock and
with that four and a half minute Gap
Andre's gonna have to play quickly I
think he'll have to play something
sharper oftentimes you hear people say I
know you want long games because you
want to try to flag your opponent you
use the clock as a weapon but I feel
like if he plays some kind of just quiet
variation that's up being Loren's alley
yeah
I
I mean I I have to say that uh
we saw when when when it was myself and
nariditsky when you were battling a uh a
water situation we we expected Sam
Savion to play C4 and play for a win in
the Armageddon not necessarily A a draw
in this case yesipenko is playing a much
more solidly this is a far less
imbalanced opening and I think we're
gonna have to restart the game because I
see the time is increasing so uh if uh
we can do that please because increment
is not part of the Armageddon so we do
have uh on apologize for the mishap here
the game has been canceled and so we
will get a fresh start uh unfortunate
for both players because they just
played some opening now they probably
have to change that up yeah well that's
that's really
that's really bad uh that's a big
mistake
uh on on on our part well
Robert and I are just talking so chess
is the kind of game where it's not like
tennis you know what I mean you you can
you just serve and it's all kind of the
same motion I mean I
that's weird okay I don't know if they
have to restart from the same position
but seemingly they're just they're being
good sports they're blitzing out the
moves I mean imagine after all that you
play E4
so that would be okay so they're both
good sports and uh wow okay that was a
disaster that we luckily don't even have
to investigate any further uh and this
is a super weird game I've I've never
seen a Catalan with all four pawns out
like this Connect Four new game and yes
the panko wins it uh but uh you know the
good thing is they didn't have time to
actually dive into the variation they
just repeated A5 played by dingline he
didn't want to give he has to make any
more space this is very strange you can
play B5 you can take that thing over
there and then play C5
I don't know this is a mess
a very very complicated and the thing is
yesipenko has to keep enough of a
position alive to either win the game
or to
get into a situation it's a draw but he
can flag dig which is
morally degrading but uh completely part
of it right so
there you go I'm just looking at this
position Bishop A6
is going to be played soon there's going
to be some clarification between these
pawns staring at one another here
I feel like black is really solid so
C5 I think is a good choice Bishop A6
natural response and look at that the
Evo art goes up to plus one how in the
world is Bishop A6 a bad move
I don't know
yeah very strange
was there a way to
like E5 or something maybe white can
play like Rook B1 Knight B5
yeah
I got some bad intentions
nasty yeah Rook fc1 Rook a B1 Knight B5
there you go Bishop F4 that's how you
see panko gotta play this game
and and I do think I understand why
Bishop race 6 is uh maybe an inaccuracy
E5 is the type of you want to play
because you get your knight here you win
the C5 Pawn not very clear in fact the
evaluation still is in White's favor
Knight D4 options uh are going to be
annoying so instead Dane just plays this
solidly and yes a panko says if you're
not gonna do anything and play passively
I'm gonna open up the position with E4
that's exactly what he wants
he might also have to time it well he
could certainly play the position and
play E4 at some point but
he also can stall we have to remember
he is up five minutes
he's not stalling though
right now
this looks great for white yeah this
looks really really good for white
controlling a lot of the board and it
says plus two and that actually seems
right because there's a weak Pawn C6
Knight's coming to E5 later okay four
oh gosh 95 to follow because because
Rook H4 black can't play Knight D5 and
if black plays H6 there might be some
sacrifice you don't want to get too
crazy though you don't want to sack and
then lose completely unnecessarily wow
Rook H4
good call by you oh man
what is ding gonna do
I have no idea but the other game is
starting right now so we'll leave ding
to think about it as we see noribbeck if
we start starts with 10 minutes on his
clock that was his bid and pancrata
plays Knight C3 will we get of Vienna oh
we do Levy wow this is a deferred King's
Gambit this is about to be sick wow
this man is so aggressive he did this
also against aviciian either later in
the game but he plays so aggressively at
times he has these
bursts of energy oh my God this is not
your back does not accept this is not
this is not a good line I mean
Knight F3 Bishop B5 here is is very good
for white I'm shocked by the move D6
well what happens is you don't face the
Vienna ever so you don't study it and
then your opponent plays it and you're
like
um what is the best line and how do I
avoid getting in huge trouble when I
don't have time to calculate it so I
think nordbeck did the Armageddon thing
he's like I'm just gonna play quick
moves even if it's a bit passive I'm
gonna go like that and
what is the I've never seen this before
I've never seen white play like the
king's Gambit declined with F4 with D6
is not good right like you're like
you're supposed to play efd D5 G5
whatever but white is just very happy
here
D3 castles Bishop B3 this is you know
solid slightly better for white we have
to go back to the other game because
dangly Ren and his fans are not going to
be happy about the position on the board
his King is under Fire and he's going to
move F5 which I have to say I like all
things considered but look at the dark
Square problems the attack that's
possible here he did kick The Rook Levy
so no more Bishop takes H6
why not
and queen G6 oh oh my goodness you're
just saying let's go for it oh my God
that's winning that's completely winning
Bishop E4 Queen F7 Etc a queen H7 it's
over
you didn't kick any Rook
um
Bishop H6 still available
so
you had something like Bishop F6 but
this Rook just goes up here and
white is better why does your stuff up
on and has the attack white has the pawn
and the compensation
oh my gosh
and Andre is calculating because this
isn't like even in this move I see what
the evaluations like he played Rook G6
first he did not take that looked a bit
unclear and he goes for this exact
variation Bishop H6 King H7 would
transpose to what we were just looking
at and with the threat of Bishop takes
E5 removing the guard of this Rook on G6
so many things in White's position are
hanging
has to not get nervous which uh he he
he's quite good at not getting nervous
he did it against the World Champ and he
was white this is wild stuff that Bishop
on A6 that Rook on A8 that Queen on C8
they are not participating the way they
would like to be White's pieces are all
pointing at the right spots except the
Rook on A1 who fell asleep but Rook will
be involved in the future right like it
feels like everything in White's
position is is working together super
super well that Bishop on F6 for black
is literally the one piece holding
everything together Knight on D5 maybe
you could argue but it can always be
taken so what an amazing position from
uh for Andre here
and he's definitely calculating Bishop
H6 King he said he takes on D5 first
he's taking a more positional approach
but maybe the bishop H6 to follow will
still be good but how to even take this
back if you take with the c Pawn you
give a pass Pawn you take with the E
Pawn you still have a problem on C6 and
we're like Bishop F4 that's not Bishop
before that's Bishop before won't be fun
in addition to Bishop takes H6 which is
still available
um
process
this is a tough spot I don't love the
move Bishop takes D5 I I literally had
just mentioned the fact that the Knight
on D5 was an important Defender and
maybe you could take it I kind of felt
like it's very hard to time moves right
there's no such thing as I'm gonna stall
you want to play the best move so you
play Bishop D5 because he thought it was
the best move but when you rush a
decision like that it could come back to
bite but okay cd5 played and like you
just said that c Pawn is gonna be
oh Queen
D1 he wants everything he wants to go
for checkmate he wants to pawn H6 he
he's not getting greedy exactly but
there might be a bishop E2 deflection at
some moment I'm like trying to figure
out how to make this work but I'm trying
to get my king to H7 with the queen H5
like take and play Bishop E2 but I think
I'm fighting off more than I could shoot
you know what I think I think it's Rook
E7 and queen E8 maybe like take rookie
seven Queen E8 somehow
oh my gosh if that works like not maybe
not now
but maybe now
there's also Rook A7 at some moment as
well but yeah this is interesting
so if King H7 Queen it comes to put on
the board real quick King H7
Queen H5 do I have Bishop E2 that's what
I've been wondering but there must be
some kind of Rook sack for these pawns
and then the king gets hunted so he did
play rookie seven Levy you're finding it
you're on fire right now Queen E8
next and if Bishop takes H6
I didn't get that far
because I actually was also just
wondering I was like
maybe now it works King H7 Queen H5
Bishop P2
oh my gosh the queen G5
oh Ingrid steals a pawn apparently not
correct but it's not what I was thinking
I thought he played rookie seven to play
Queen E8 but
yeah let's actually look at that was
Queen Y8 the better move because Queen
E8 yes it in fact it was wow Queen H5
looks very reasonable but you know we
mentioned Bishop E2 yeah Queen G5 this
looks scary even though it's saying that
it's good for black I guess Rook A7 King
H7 things like that is trapped King H7
traps The Rook in the future that's
absurd yeah this is very difficult
perfect example of Unstoppable Force
meets an immovable object right like you
just bulldoze and black is just Rock
Solid wow what a position I'm telling
you I think Andre rushed it okay he
rushed it just a little bit
but he's still up five minutes so right
and his arm again you survived long
enough
could still win yeah this King on G is
never going to be safe the problem is
this Rook is trapped in here so if you
make one misstep you're not just gonna
lose your advantage you might just lose
your rook and E6 is hanging yeah I
forgot about that but then there's D4
Queen D5 Bishop B7 and then the attack
turns for black so uh we're gonna go
back to the other game because there are
two games going on we don't want to uh
lose out on both I think this one is
more interesting uh for the moment but
the last few moves I've seen a rook come
to F5 after capturing E5 and now on
Karate takes here what's the material
count an extra Pawn for white but sort
of awkward peace placement
yeah I don't know wow this is a this is
super super complicated that white has
just the past a pawn for no reason I
gotta listen I Gotta Give I Gotta Give
love to my man buncratic here I really
think that
I really think
he's the one that's actually pushing
this game it's unreal he might actually
be the favorite here which is just
unbelievable uh let's let's let these
guys figure it out I think I think we
have a lot of life here I feel like that
Ding game ding is under some severe
pressure there to try to defend so
let's go let's go focus on that one
because we we will have this game even
after I think the Zing game finishes
considering I think it started a bit
earlier uh yes panko apparently didn't
find the right way forward
again Rook C8
what a move for C8
apparently what is one is wrong is there
like I'm I'm still looking at two ideas
but I don't think it's necessary there's
no threat right now
that black has to worry about besides
the queen hanging obviously yeah besides
that it's a small thing but uh well if
black trades Queen wow yes taking away
access from the queen joining the party
this is a this is very bad scenario
Queenie one yeah Andre has to play for a
win apparently that's not the right way
to do it Queen A6 you're saying yeah
this is bad protected here this queen is
not active King F7 is about no sorry
King H7 is going to win a piece because
the Rook will be in Jack and the bishop
king of seven would just blend to the
pawn cutting off The Rook but either way
the attack
seems to be behind him and now dingley
Ren has the upper hand he does have the
upper hand this will forever go down as
yesi panko had a great position but try
to clarify things concretely a little
bit too fast that trait of the bishop on
D5 it removed an important defender of
Black's position but it removes such an
integral piece of the white setup that
now those light scored weaknesses are
going to be permanent and you see a
sepenko like he's been doing a good job
kind of playing the poker element of
this game as in I'm just gonna play fast
but uh ding doesn't care about all that
play fast stuff he's playing the best
moves
taking a bunch of time now is Andre
casapenko he's spoiled what was a very
promising position it was complicated
was not simple and it never has been uh
but this position now just simply looks
better for buck in fact this is a losing
move it says minus six
I wonder if black can just like go for
some checkmating ideas
probably or uh D4
oh no gosh
Rod the red carpet for this Pond it is
just marching up the board there's no
attack everything is defending something
in Black's position all the pieces on
great squares
oh gosh you know for Andre this is not a
good moment
no Queen G3 clean
can you sack the queen and play D3
that is sick
no way right okay he's not gonna do it
but like I don't know it's much easier
to sack my my you know
someone I'm spectating their Queen not
my own Queen if rookie six Bishop D5
have a queen F3 you don't just sacrifice
your queen you're just going straight in
for checkmate this is very promising
just winning
it's for science that's results oh no
look at Andre he can't believe it yeah
this really is devastating this is not
title Tuesday this is not just the
random Blitz game this was the game to
make it to the round of 16 and yes you
panko he knows and he also definitely
knows that
he missed the chance when he was
attacking
I feel for him
I feel for him oh he can't he can't
believe it it's hard to watch honestly
because Andre yesapenko won game one
with black a very nice game then in game
three dingley wrench Strikes Back
going up a pawn in in opening variation
that was complicated and ending up with
a win and then here in Armageddon I mean
Andre was in the offensive and now he
looks like he's in the verge of tears I
feel for him he's just 20 years old his
future is so bright but uh it's hard to
watch this
yeah yeah you definitely feel for him
and ding I mean to be honest if you if
you were to paint a thing you you would
you you would see it's the same kind of
reaction I mean it's almost like oh
there we go okay now ding kind of smiled
there we go
okay
there we go ding
thank you for the emotion uh
and he knows he knows the light squares
are are going to be game game over here
Andre plays Rook D6
and then capture Queen F3 and
yeah D3 Rook C2 I mean there's some
there yeah D3 threatens Queen H1 made I
think that's remember it draws all
dignity red needs so if he wants you can
play Bishop C4 check and then Bishop
back to D5 on the King goes to G1 so
he's going for checkmate oh gosh this is
brutal this is over and yeah dingly Ren
is moving on the one seed in his group
on his side of the bracket and with this
Victory he will face the winner of the
other Armageddon game so uh maybe we'll
wait to see Andre resign but I really do
want to get back to the other game where
Pavel pankratov has nine minutes 41
seconds his opponent no Rebecca I've
done a two and a half minutes and all
right well this is resigned to Queen D1
Levy yeah oh yeah that's that's yeah
that's definitely tough yeah guys we
I feel like this is this is not fair
anymore can we please can we go back to
our uh I mean I guess we're gonna see
the final move of the game or yeah the
final moment there it is uh dangly Ren
he's so happy I mean he's counting his
lucky stars there because he was about
to be eliminated from the tournament
look at him what a Chad walking uh
walking out of the screen uh out of our
the camera view with the Rival chess
tournament hoodie I mean look at what a
flex can we get some can we get some
hoodies for the players guys so that
when they turn around they don't have
the name of a different event on the
back of their honey thank you I would
really appreciate that just good
marketing I feel like dingley run what a
beast uh coming back from from one nil
down and this is the biggest development
of the day this is shocking yeah I mean
obviously we had our Marquee matchup
with dingley Wren getting by in in the
Armageddon versus yesi panko
robertov is going to be vishi Anand and
the reigning defending World rapid
Champion what is going on
that's what happens when you're a strong
Grandmaster who may not have the 2700
rating but you're a very darn good at
chess so uh you get overlooked people
question who is this person how do they
make it here and then you realize wait
this person's been a Grandmaster for how
long who did they beat over the board so
right now Han kratzov is up in exchange
black has a knight and one Pawn for this
great it ran away this great Rook on B1
that's about to try to deliver a
Checkmate so Nordic is desperately
trying to get a defense with his Knight
on the back Rank and it's not that
simple I don't see the clear
breakthrough just yet
no me neither it's it's got to beat
something gotta be something I mean you
can always trade the Queens but easier
said than done
right you do not want to give up this
Pawn over here on C5
no you don't unless you're gonna win the
night but if you give up the pawn on C5
it's unwinnable anymore so
actually if this queen takes is a queen
E6 check so I'm just gonna make some
random moves so uh we can get there like
a
okay great move if this Pawn is captured
there's Queen E6 check and then Queen to
F7 and this Knight has to move and it
actually has nowhere to go it's trapped
because Knight G6 runs into Queen G8
check and mate so we have the queen
returning to E3 protecting the pawn but
look at the setup Levy I'm not saying
that nordeback's gonna hold this game
but I'm feeling like he should be
increasingly confident with the last few
moves this is crazy though he's got two
minutes and no bonus time that's it he's
got two minutes for the remainder of the
game I mean literally if white wanted he
could Shuffle pieces back and forth for
49 moves
keep offering trades push upon and
there's nothing no jailbreak can do
like there is a world where 50 60 moves
from now knows your back just loses on
time because he cannot do anything
he is a great bullet player and rookie 8
was a nice move making sure the Knight
could get to E6 but watch out if you
lose this Pawn all of a sudden it
looking more Josh can you take it as a
rook E5 that's why he puts King on H2
great move
yep
yep yep yep and by the way rookin 2
versus knight and two is holdable for
sure uh for the Knight and two but not
with 150 I mean you're gonna get flagged
it's just
you're just gonna get flagged there's no
way there's nothing you can do
and on kratza the guy hasn't really
moved a muscle look at him he has a
statue he's just focusing on the chest
and that goes to F6 you are right though
Levy it's a really good point that even
if these pawns get traded white will
move forever give you a pawn move upon
whatever and just flag you so pankrantev
I don't know what his Blitz and bullet
skills are like but if he just looks at
the clock he should be certain he's
going to win the game
I'm trying to
see yeah he's like uh 2 900 Blitz and he
doesn't play a whole lot of bullet
plays mostly uh
but uh
plays the slightly slower time controls
but
yeah well
take on C5 this is rookie five the
geometry is unreal
that's there's always these tactics yep
that's sick which means it's just game
over
if you can't win the pawn on C5 you are
done for Queen comes to D6 and you're
losing on the board doesn't matter what
the clock
this is shocking
this is an absolutely shocking turn of
events I'm not gonna lie to you I sort
of was like well that was a big first
round upside for pyville but you know
now he's taking on noiseer back and you
just sort of think well no dear bags
load your bags got it
it's anything but that it's literally
anything but that uh the the this man is
on a mission it's gonna be giri
pankrative
who would have thought that and I I
guess I
misspoke mentioning dingley Wren playing
the winner of this match you are right
Geary plays the winner of this match and
it is looking like it's going to be Punk
cross if there's unless you blunder a
Perpetual check
like you know Queen F4 situation which
you can't when there's a queen E5 the
game is over
yep that's it this isn't even this isn't
even a flagging situation of course it
can be but
yeah for the second time today we see
the head in their hands because they
they were in positions to potentially be
winning the match
just in this case actually really did
seem to be a step behind pancratav
throughout today like I that's not a
knock on the player he's just he never
had a chance like it really just somehow
felt like even the game pancaratov just
went totally crazy from start to finish
it's been Punk's match to sort of
giveaway today really uh and noji but
can't believe it I can't believe it does
the champion of the world in in Rapid
format and
yeah
it's a four game match plus the
Armageddon anything can happen and Norm
he was up one half half we can't forget
that in game three pancrata played a
brilliant game with the black pieces he
wins now nordbeck lets his time elapse
and that means that Pavel pankratov
continues to break brackets and hearts
he moves on to the round of 16.
yeah just the spectacular
spectacular upset for for Bible
pongratov maybe not in his mind maybe he
doesn't he doesn't think of it as an
upset maybe he thinks of it as there is
no reason why I can't be winning these
matches he gets uh a king's Gambit on
the board
and he just plays a marvelous Armageddon
game for the second time winning with
the white pieces on command in the uh in
the last game of the day
massive congratulations to him and
what more can we say amazing stuff it
was a big moment because he actually
took with the wrong Pawn from the
objective evaluation but I like C takes
B3 because of what was happening in the
game this Pawn started running up the
board and with less time on the clock
it's very difficult to meet these
problems so A4 was played then A5 said
look at that Rook A5 just to go back to
eight that's a step that just you can't
take back and white just took advantage
pushing D4 as well the Knight is loose
on F4 so you can't take on D4 and then
simply went ahead and won the pawn E5
and that's sort of where we tuned in and
then tuned back out but great tactical
Vision to give up a night bring the Rook
back Levy this seems like a fantastic
game from Punk routes off
truly truly everything from the opening
Choice which was exotic we didn't see
some typical Catalan whatever just you
know Rue Lopez just everything
everything about this was was was great
from start to finish it really felt like
for 90 of today's match pankrative was
the guy applying the pressure
and for the 10 it was when he just went
completely crazy in in the pawn up end
game and ended up losing uh he is having
the Cinderella story of the tournament
You could argue that Sam Savion taking
down mvl or serrana taking down Mami jar
of here in the round of 32 was
substantial this man just took out the
champion of the world in Rapid format
and that was after he took down arguably
a top five player of all time multiple
time classical world champion the
schwanathan Anand there is no one who is
having a better storyline in the
chess.com Global Championship than five
El pancrath of so massive
congratulations to him and he will play
a niche giri to determine which of those
two is going to make it to a live Final
in Toronto if he beats Anish giri I
don't even know I better get his
autograph in Toronto you better sign my
face
and that's why I love this tournament
though is because uh in the Chess World
we often see the same 15 faces over and
over again with some of the younger
generation now sprinkling in to the
competition but Pavel pankratov he's
been waiting his whole life to Showcase
his talent he's a grand master he has
earned the highest title that's not
world champion in chess but he is one of
the best players in the world and that
means in any individual game he could
beat the best players in the world in a
four-game match he's proven himself to
beat vishciano to beat nordi Becca
busitarov and we'll see if he could take
down a top 10 player in the world in
Anish giri in the next one so we'll
bring up the bracket so we can just
dissect what has occurred and what's
going to happen next look there on the
middle right of your screen Anish giri
the one seed plays the Cinderella Pavel
Punk the seventh seed super exciting
just an amazing Story coming out of
group F and the winner will no longer be
playing online they will be going to the
finals in Toronto of course pending
travel issues Visa issues whatever but
just what an amazing story I hope a
niche didn't spend too much time
preparing ahead of time for another
because that all has to go out the
window now Bible pancrata presents a
very unique matchup uh in the sense of
openings in the sense of style and that
is who we can expect to play uh I mean
not not expect to play this is simply
going to be our finals of group F we
also though had another group today so
maybe we can check in on Group G and the
live uh the the last final match there
is set as dingley Ren the one seed will
take on nihal sarin uh to be honest he
could have been the three or the two
seed very tricky of course kramnik being
world champion and having a high rapid
rating is one thing but nihal Saran I
think way more experience in this online
speeches format
I I think it's not controversial and
it's not uh it's not shocking to get
dingly Wren versus someone here but
Robert we we've been saying it from the
beginning dingley wren's been a bit
shaky even against Juan Mila against
Andreas panko will it continue or will
that sort of change and will he have a
dominant display in this final match up
in group G what do you think
yeah he's kind of flying so close to the
Sun there where he's just getting away
with it is dingley Ren but when he plays
nihal sarin I don't think that Neil's
letting anyone off the hook he barely
made it through like milliseconds on his
clock against Ralph mahmetov in the
opening round today his strength was on
full display two solid draws then a
victory and a Time scramble so you know
you call it a bullet Victory whatever
you want to say but he wasn't really
worse in the match against krumnick he
held his own against the former world
champion somebody who's won the best
players of all time it's clear how
strong nihal sarin is so uh it's going
to be exciting but what also is exciting
is the upcoming matches that are getting
underway in just over an hour
yeah we've got the matchups of group a e
and H because we know how to do the
alphabet Nakamura versus David Navara
nipom Nichi versus svidler and Levon
aronian will take on Maxim matlakov now
if you ask the audience of these six who
do they know least they might say Maxim
matlakov will we have another epic run
of Russian Grandmaster taking down uh
the favorite there I mean matlakov
taking down aranyan might be just as
epic as pankrat of taking down uh not
your back but when you add the fact that
he's also beaten a guy in viciana and
what more can you say uh we will be
bringing you that match up with I
believe Daniel narodiski and I'm on
Hamilton but if I'm wrong uh please do
not be mad at me that could oh I'm right
okay thanks producer
the chat didn't hear that I just heard
you're right I don't know if that was
God or the producer in my ear but uh
looks like I'm right and uh that's
that's all for today I hope you enjoyed
the coverage Robert
we have to wake up at 5am but we do get
to see some pretty amazing chess and we
will be back uh quite soon with the
coverage of the remaining games
literally the remaining games actually
in the round of 32 with the exception of
rajabov and Eric icy who we will just
have play live on stream at some point
and definitely not off stream but we
don't know when that's gonna happen it
all depends on uh on scheduling that
will probably be in a few days but we'll
see you all back here in one hour for
the near conclusion of the round of 32
in the chess.com Global championship
thanks everybody
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you